[Music]
two
welcome welcome everybody it is monday
may 2nd we are here it is the h3 podcast
give it up it's monday they said we
would never make it
monday but here we are
against all the odds
and we actually have a really good show
here for a change today
do we
i'd like to think so okay
you know
welcome everybody
hope you had a good weekend right at the
top i want to give a special thank you
to hello fresh
new oh abs burrito
it's just been a minute you know i
really noticed that that burrito does
have kind of a six pack i saw i know
someone edited that with your six-pack
but that burrito is more jacked than you
are yeah it's a
good-looking burrito
too bad there's tacks in it inside of it
could be i don't know it could be
anything could be whatever you want
new season means new seasonal recipes
and now it's easier than ever with fresh
ingredients delivered to your door
hellofresh brings the market the farmers
market to you get 16 free meals plus
three
gifts
with code h3tv16
at hellofresh.com
h3tv16 thank you to hellofresh
love you guys
love their food too
also excited to announce this friday
bobby lee and kalila are coming on uh
for a
is this their third or fourth appearance
i think it would be third yeah
thanks dan so you know it's always so
fun when you have bobby lee in the
studio the guy is ridiculously funny
and uh we always have a lot of fun when
he's in the studio and kleil is awesome
too so
that's exciting
leftovers on thursday live at 10 a.m
assuming that uh hassan doesn't catch
another uh
virus of some kind yeah maybe he'll
he'll come down with a super covet or
something
but
right now we're planning on that
that's right that's right that's right
i am coming here i'm in the midst of
another allergic reaction you guys
probably remember the cortisone drama
where my face was getting puffier
as the show went on i don't know what
the f is going on
i've been off wellbutrin for three days
and kind of that it's not really gone
away
so i don't know what's causing this
allergic reaction i don't know that you
can see it very well but my skin
is so raw and itchy
you know i'm all hopped up on uh
benadryl
i don't know what benadryl i mean it
stops the itch for like a few hours
which is nice but then it just comes
back and i'm just sleepy as hell but
it's better than nothing i guess no way
okay
[Laughter]
rest in peace by the way to mobility oh
yeah rest in peace
um i know you guys had a fun weekend
zach played a show that was a banger he
sold the whole thing out it was a lot of
fun
it was a lot of fun i think congrats
zach thank you i want to thank everyone
that came out and uh it was electric it
was a good time the whole gang was there
too right yeah you all had fun yeah it
was a blast yep he rocked the house
cam got trashed
there's some funny clips of cam you're
feeling okay cam
yeah i'm feeling great so did you have
to pay for those drinks or were they
free
i'm sorry again were the drinks free or
did you have to pay for them
uh well
i wasn't saying no to drinks
oh i see i see so fans were wanting to
uh show their love to you yeah i got
bought a few drinks as well that's so
nice it was very nice and what a great
thing thank you very much a bunch of
dudes and gals
great crowd i mean phenomenal crowd
good time oh that's so fun you know you
guys were playing at nine o'clock i was
still putting the kids to sleep
so i was like
i was trying i was thinking maybe i'd
come to this one
and we me and eel were both like in baby
mode
actually can i can i make a a specific
uh announcement or statement or apology
i guess oh okay so
when i first got there
uh i come in the back and i stepped out
uh into like the main area
trying to make my way to the bar
to get a drink because i just arrived
and immediately somebody came up to me
this guy and he was like yo what's up
man i'm a huge fan can i take a picture
i'm like absolutely i'm gonna come back
right here
[Laughter]
i'm going to come back right here in a
few minutes
let me get a drink first and then a b
and i took like three more steps and
like four more people walked up and
asked for a picture and i like
immediately gave up and started taking
pictures with people and then once i
finally made my way to the back got a
drink i came back and that person was
nowhere to be found
and i realized from their perspective i
walk in
say you know sorry no pictures and then
immediately take like 40 pictures with
fans like right after him oh
wow and i was really guilty about all
night i was looking for him but i
couldn't it's dark in there i couldn't
quite find him
so
if i did that to you i apologize so this
time
is issuing an apology to the mysterious
young man was it who he who he
murderously blew off
who went home in a fit of
humiliation and rage i wonder if they
left after that because they weren't
there when i got back i don't think he
was upset just talking from experience
like it's people know [ __ ] happens you
get swarmed in the situation i doubt
he's holding a grudge i think he
actually came back but he was in a
larger group so you may not notice okay
so maybe even got the picture of him
it was bothering me there you have it
dan is
a
a gentle soul and he
has not forgotten the young man who he
may have offended but we love them all
right
would you recognize his face if he came
back to another show
um
[Music]
that's the biggest insult whoever you
are yeah
here's a here's a little super clip of
zack shredding it up what's the name of
your band zack it's just my name zach
lewis oh the zack lewis experience yes
so you're like uh
elton john kind of like that yeah but
it's they back you up yeah but i i don't
i don't like to you know me and my bass
player zack are like really tight you're
both zach we're both zach we used to go
by the name andrews lewis
that was like our little solo project
but since i started performing and i
just use my name so maybe we'll have a
band name but so is it the zach lewis
experience or just zach lewis just zach
lewis
zach lewis experience could be good
though yeah
i like that yeah
maybe i'll roll with that next time so
so let's watch
is that your dad
that's todd i met i met the todd we met
on saturday for the first time
oh yeah i heard you had a fun this is
zack's dad the todd the dog the chub
i think he was actually yeah he tucks in
he's got a little bit of a chub and tuck
and i call it the todd and tuck
and i'm just here to play some good
[ __ ] music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh i saw sean tall was tearing it up too
that was nuts she was like straight
tearing it up zach yeah she was having a
good time
that's pretty cool i didn't know she was
like uh
she's sh i don't i don't know if rhodey
is an offensive word
is it manager she's like a manager she's
the manager but she was just she was
really loving it yeah she was having a
good time brody's not offensive by her
uh what rody's not offensive yes because
she's kind of like you're she's your
biggest fan she follows you right she
dances she's getting into it yeah no she
was having a great time
[Applause]
oh no
damn boy
you're gonna have to light that thing on
fire when you're done with it
[Music]
oh no
were you on your knee
[Applause]
that was really cool
they started doing that on their own we
didn't prompt them to do that you know i
was wondering oh it's almost done
[Applause]
family
wow what a fun thing you know i was
wondering if we should think about doing
a live podcast here in la again
finally that'd be dope i'm warming back
up let's do it i'm warming back up to
the idea let's go
yeah i don't know i don't want to do i
wouldn't want to take the show on the
road like a lot of podcasts do
necessarily because i don't want to be
away from the family family family
family yeah but i think doing a local
show live would be a lot of fun yeah we
gotta find a better like uh
touring manager though because that last
one was a nightmare
yeah i mean that was what kind of turned
you off to it is we had sort of a bad
experience with one company but um you
know that there's a million companies
that do that and dude it was one of them
accomplished so stupid yeah they did
blow that pretty bad
yeah that could be fun what do you guys
think i think that that would be a fun
experience the audience has been
the audience wants it they've been
asking for it forever we all want it
we've been nagging about it you guys
want to do it because it's a lot of work
for you guys
oh yeah i love you though yeah okay
we'll do it live because the one we did
was awesome that was so much fun yeah
so i guess we'll just try to find a
touring company and take it from there
and just set it up
yeah maybe we can talk to some of our
friends in the podcast space that do
this often and get a recommendation this
time
from somebody that
sets up these tours all the time
do it like once a month live
if that's what you want to do yeah
i guess let's do it once and see if it
goes well yeah let's do it once yeah
before we uh
anyway so okay that's something i'm
thinking about you know okay
everybody's saying london
london let's go to london
try some real beans on toast dude i'm
not even willing to go to like [ __ ]
i'm not even going to like yeah san
diego's out of the question little in
london
how about sweden ethan
sweden
the fun thing about going on the road is
that a lot of people turn up though for
you sure i feel like when you go on the
road
absolutely people are driving from all
over oh yeah there were a few people
there were people that came from
sacramento wow
uh utah
canada whoa i talked to
somebody from kentucky mm-hmm
goddamn chucky way really dude
i just got flashbacks when we planned
that second live show and we had to
cancel it and then i was like refunding
hordes of people out of pocket yep for
flights in hotels
that was freaking nightmare i think i
must have spent like twenty thousand
dollars refunding people was it that
much or was it like no no no like ten
thousand
it
it might have got up to that it was a lo
i mean this is five years ago so yeah we
were working with like
uh
wme yes it was wme which i don't know
anything about their traditional
management i don't give a [ __ ] i'm never
working with those [ __ ]
but they have the digital management and
they're just i don't know
they started selling tickets without
telling us and they jacked the price way
up
yeah we were having a meeting to discuss
all of that and then in the meeting they
just randomly were like okay so it's
been on sale since yesterday yeah
and we were like what nobody asked you
to do that and uh yeah just
you got pissed off and then [ __ ] this
whole thing and then there was like a
huge fee for the venue which we didn't
talk about and then so after i argue
with them they're like okay we can
reduce it by we can reduce their feed to
like zero
or something like drastic i was like
that's why the [ __ ] you shouldn't have
put it on sale already
and it was just the whole thing was
just soured me so i cancelled it and
then people started emailing like i had
a plane ticket hotel that i already
spent money on this non-refundable and i
was like [ __ ] i just started paying all
these people out of pocket because i
felt bad and uh
that was a miserable experience yeah so
that's why there hasn't been a live show
in four years or whatever i've been
recuperating from that
trying to make the money back still
there you have it
yeah nice
um here is cam uh faded as they say
oh this is uh one of our great
moderators
uh angry or no avery avery avery but
what's his name oh my god
yeah sweet guy man shout out avery i
know you're probably watching you're the
man thank you for everything here he is
with cam unfortunately avery i don't
think cam registered anything you were
saying but i'm sure it was really
interesting
football thing because it's bakersfield
as [ __ ] we got pumpkin and flavor love
we got like pleasure not all the crazy
[ __ ] they can't [ __ ]
cocktail but like
cam could you kim were you able to
register what he was saying
dude i remember everything i looked way
worse than i felt yeah he was cold
yeah
oh man it looked like you were in the
shadow realm
it wasn't quite that far
well
hmm maybe it's more motor my motor
functions were off because you can tell
that i'm like leaning on to him heavily
right here because i couldn't stand on
my own two feet
but uh you know i we were talking about
football here and i
uh i remember everything that was said
that night you're talking about football
he was talking about flavor of love
characters
no he was talking about football he he
did bring a flavor of love i don't know
how that tied in i was too distracted by
cam but
they were talking about the flavor of
love the old reality show yeah you just
said pumpkin from flavor of love that
was the part that i caught so it didn't
sound very football related i think she
worked at his high school or something
like that okay well yeah okay he has
recollection he's picking up but we're
talking about football okay
um here's some memes from the subreddit
that were great
this is dan shame on you for not being
in the pool you freak
dude this [ __ ] [ __ ] killed me wait is
that why did someone draw this
i think it was an existing thing and it
was probably the reverse they flipped
the colors
oh that's crazy as hell that's a great
edit though
30 who regularly do it 77 of the
audience 6 who have taken shits in the
pool
[Laughter]
oh that's so good yeah i'm sorry
i've has i feel like that may have uh
shaken shaking you to the core of that
revelation it was a little upsetting it
was definitely a shocking one hey it's
better to know than not know i guess oh
yeah
oh you know what's funny though i was
telling you more i was telling ali about
it uh this weekend
how that had happened on the show and
it's like am i [ __ ] crazy and she
agreed with me she was like no i've
never peed in the pool that's weird
she's like that reminds me that's like
adults who pee in the shower and i was
like
uh-oh
bro everyone can be in the shower that's
ridiculous i do it with everyone there's
nothing wrong with being in the shower i
mean peeing in the pool i get where you
can be upset even though everyone does
it peeing in the shower come on you
can't talk [ __ ] about that yeah maybe
i'm gonna pee in my trash can down here
trash can that's a little grosser there
quartering i can't let that one slide
uh here's of course my dad we were
talking about animals my dad turning
into a beach ball
[Laughter]
you know yeah there's a bunch of these
he's about to commit
seppuku oh true
i didn't want to have to do this
yeah
um here i am turning to master chief
okay fair enough
gabe turning into a white claw of course
ian turning into a lego man this is my
favorite yeah is this something that's
been observed ian the lego man thing or
what's the story here you don't remember
what
friday he told the story about how he
thought he could turn to a lego when he
went into legoland oh i see it's a
little meme crossover because i was like
you do look like the lego man
although what's weird is this one looks
like me this stage of ian
oh wow that's interesting
there's a little of me and you ian
beautiful
and of course this was my favorite
uh the seamless transition of harvey
weinstein turning into ryan cavanaugh
hollywood scum i thought it was harvey
weinstein just getting younger
oh oh wait is it let me hmm i think they
might have missed the point of this
morphing because you're supposed to
change from one thing it's just harvey
getting younger yeah brian kavanagh is
the force of nature
hey speaking of ryan cavanaugh did we
update the website yet um love
i
i think so i don't know because there
was the the the charity thing i wanted
to add
right yeah i have it drafted oh oh no
it's up it's up
it is up
yeah yeah if you guys type in google
ryan kavanagh
it's important you type it out
and then click the website
we added a new section that's important
to brush up on
um
threatened critics unpaid wages ponzi
we added that's a segment so where's the
the donation part
further down oh
oh okay we should add it to the timeline
too
right sure yeah
yeah but here hell ryan cavanaugh failed
to deliver 1 million also by variety
interesting
this is awesome
it's awesome dude yeah it's really great
it's awesome right and now from one
incredible partner yeah you get we've
been over it but oh there's like a whole
thing about it
oh
something i messed up all right got
duplicated
well there you have it so yeah check out
the website brush up on your on your
knowledge
um
did we look at all the memes i think so
yeah there goes it
and then
oh wait
zach just stepped away and we need him
for that so maybe just come back
yeah
because we can't play the music on it
but he has some other music but he's not
here so
we could just come back to it later
he wanted to show this right here
i kept helping cam out of the club
someone sent this to cam
it's pretty funny someone sent someone
took this a third party took this yeah
okay
[Music]
it's not that bad he's definitely
stumbling
looking back i
probably shouldn't have been as open
about accepting drinks but you know it
worked out at the happy ending in the
end so thank you very much for buying me
drinks throughout the night guys well
what you weren't like soliciting drinks
like don't buy me a drink no people just
uh came up to me and gave me a glass of
a mystery drink so
but
you know well
i didn't say no there you go but it
worked out
we got to get you one of those straws
that changes colors if there's like gbd
in it or whatever ghb ghb yeah
can you buy those uh online
ghb straws we gotta we got to put it on
a necklace and just give it to cam
uh
i'm not seeing like an
obvious link to i see a lot of articles
talking about it
i'm not sure where you got those
well while we wait for zach you know we
got a new
okay so this was the katy perry one or
is this something else
it's katy perry it's the case yeah so
katy perry ate [ __ ] again didn't you on
that on purpose
she's kind of a goober i don't know
yeah but she's so she's she's at the
beginning the way she's seated
i can see how friends at all wait uh oh
here yes dude okay i'm sorry but katy
perry i from seeing her be such a public
figure on on these shows
she really needs a lot of attention
i've noticed tonight your top ten are
trying to win you over again
well
oh they love her they love her they
really love her
all right
well
there you have it guys tv is
really poppin
wait i gotta ask did anyone watch the
ozark yet
i did you watch the whole thing
anyone else too
is anyone avoiding spoilers samus we're
we're watching it now
please god don't spawn
i'm not going to spoil but i want to
tell you what i thought is that okay sam
yeah that's fine it was so [ __ ] bad
it was such dog [ __ ] it was almost
comparing to game of thrones bad i won't
say it was that bad but the whole last
half of the last season was just
mind-numbingly [ __ ]
dumb like oh my god you will go on this
whole journey with these people and they
just they just dropped the ball
so hard at the end there i mean
you loved it i'm getting the
no i know i didn't like it
i thought it could have been worse but
i don't know how it could have been
worse it was
after the the first episode of this
second part when they
took care of things in that first
episode i was like okay now where is the
season going to go because
everyone assumed that's where the plot
was going but
yeah i wasn't happy with it
i'm not spoiling it i'm just telling you
oh people are saying it they liked it
okay
well some people have no taste so that's
that's good for you no i i saw
there's a mix for sure
guys it was so bad what the hell before
you even said what you thought about it
i saw people saying the ending [ __ ]
sucked it was just i found it so
disappointing guys i'm not i'm not
saying anything
i don't like it
but um
wait how did i spoil it by saying i
didn't like it that's the same thing
when i said i didn't like batman
i said it but you said you made a plot
point you made a plot you set up a bomb
exploded it's a batman movie
no but you what did you say happened in
the beginning because you did a spoiler
oh the very opening scene oh i said it i
just said the opening scene was just a
boring long shot of a family that had
nothing to do with the story that's a
[ __ ] take amy
so a b spoiled at you guys i spoiled it
i didn't do anything people saying best
ending ever wow
what on god's green earth everyone saw
that
holy [ __ ]
i was saying it's bad spoiling like
you've you
your dips
people are saying i'm pulling a sean
right now hell no i didn't say [ __ ] i
just said i don't like it
but i am watching um
i'm almost done with the first season of
raised by wolves on hbo and that show is
real nice
and i need to emphasize that severance
on apple tv is one of the best shows
i've ever seen
i've been seeing a lot of hype about it
wow that was a great show the plot the
story the acting
super super good race by wolves is that
kind of like surreal science fiction
show right it's not surreal
i don't know why they market it like
really bizarrely but it's not surreal
it's just a cool science fiction show
really well done high end good acting
good writing
it's not super weird i don't know why
it's branded like that because i'll
admit before i clicked on it i was like
this [ __ ] looks weird as hell it's not
it's really not that weird
people are saying watch the sopranos i
believe that uh i've had plenty of
opportunity to watch that show and i
have
so thank you for yeah i think you guys
should watch um
this great little show called uh
mash yeah mash have you guys heard of
ever this obscure spoilers
[Laughter]
you remember the show seinfeld seinfeld
no spoilers please scene filled yeah
listen i love jason bateman too and i
thought he was great
i'll wait a week okay you all have a
week to watch it then i'm gonna spoil
this [ __ ] okay you guys are on notice
it's only like six episodes so get to
work you have one week your ass is on
notice
because i have a lot i want to talk
about with that that i have so many
problems with the way that whole thing
developed
it's hard to end the show it has been
proven time and it is again it's hard
it's hard
yeah i agree
yeah the wire is probably one of the
best shows ever made if you haven't seen
that but it's old as [ __ ] really good
though
i am watching barry
barry's a great show is barry's still
going on yeah the new season just came
out just two episodes are out i have to
come back to that i've only watched the
first season
do you watch a better call saul ethan
you know i i watched the first few apps
or seasons and then i kind of bailed
because i felt it was just taking too
long to get to the [ __ ] point me too
and i love breaking bad i and i i was
really enjoying it but at a certain
point and and better call saul i was
just kind of pulling my hair out because
the show was not going anywhere they
were dragging their [ __ ] heels with
like
plot and i i just couldn't i couldn't do
it anymore like i couldn't watch another
episode where nothing happens i just
couldn't do it the the season five is
one of the best things i've ever seen
and they're on the last season now
season six
but um
i i happen to think it's really good i'd
put it up there with breaking bad i do
think it's very good like it's obviously
a good show it's just
i don't know
they wore me out i feel you i mean i can
see it
um
but you know i gotta say like of all the
streaming stuff i've been messing with
netflix is just not they i see what's
going on netflix they make a lot of [ __ ]
like they don't make a lot of good shows
their thing is like turned into they
used to make great shows but they've
turned into quantity over quality
and i go on there and it's just a bunch
of shitty shows where if you look at hbo
max they don't make that many shows but
the vast majority of hbo
shows are [ __ ] good like really good
and that's what brings me
to
to their platform and i gotta give it up
to apple tv too i [ __ ] hate apple
i hate everything they do i think
they're just evil scum but apple tv
slaps their shows are good
really good what do they got what's on
there they have
severance which is one of my favorite
shows ever oh okay
the morning show was incredible such a
good show
they have um
now they made that foundation show which
everybody said was uh disappointing
oh a ted uh lasso is like that show's
massive and very good oh that's on apple
yeah okay yeah so like right there's
three really high quality shows you know
and netflix i can't [ __ ] name like
anything that i'm interested in watching
there i said that the other day and you
pushed back on me well i just started
yeah i just started to really feel it
lately i gotta say yeah
yeah i canceled it when they raised the
price so just like not not worth it
anymore
yeah apple tv and hbo max man those are
those are the ones that i'm really
loving lately
lots of controversy in the chat people
are
oh yeah
hey let's do a poll this would be
interesting what what is your favorite
streaming platform hbo max
apple tv
netflix prime your max prime nobody
likes prime a lot of people are saying
the boys well the boys is [ __ ] great
but you can't rate it based on one show
i mean it's free so basically no they
have that other one uh that science
fiction one day and hassan was watching
it
the man in the tower whatever uh oh well
they do have that oh you're probably
thinking of the expanse the expansion oh
but yeah but they just bought the rights
to that show they didn't really make it
the expense is so good though you got to
watch that ethan i'll watch raise by
watching you check out the expansion i i
watched the first season of it oh you
did yeah a while ago
try and get back into it but then add
hula talk about shows that stuck the
ending because it it finished oh they
did and the ending rocks that's really
[ __ ] good
well that's good yeah so we have hbo hbo
max apple tv
or apple plus what the [ __ ] is their
[ __ ] called yeah apple apple plus apple
plus i've always had the theory that
they're going to buy out netflix so it
could be apple plus netflix
uh
what else is
netflix disney netflix i mean then
basically the only only four options
right there yeah so we have to decide
between hulu and disney plus
now i think hulu i have hulu i paid for
it
hulu is like [ __ ] the tv graveyard
but it's a lot of people are saying hula
though all right let's do hulu
hulu owns disney plus i'm sorry disney
owned yeah i was like
confused yeah so people are saying add
hulus go for that all right here we go
people some people are saying cnn plus
people are saying quibby
some people are saying youtube red
[Music]
i think for my money right now
yeah hbo max wow i mean it's the clear
and by the way one of our sponsors so
yep shout out this is a sponsored
segment thank you all for participating
it's not it's not i wish it was
i've always felt that it was the best
streaming service well hbo hbo since its
inception has consistently been
one of the best content producers even
before the streaming era they have made
the best shows the wire
made curb what sopranos they they like
they have this they have this philosophy
there that they just make the best thing
possible i mean game of thrones you know
what i mean hbo just they don't [ __ ]
miss it's just such a good business
model of just posting great [ __ ] and not
[ __ ] posting non-stop like netflix is
doing
[Music]
so that's real interesting to me that
y'all are riding for hbo max
that's cool
hbo max has all the harry potter movies
well there you go if you're trying to uh
shift shift
that's the place to go
zach are you back can i play this sitcom
thing
yes my apologies did you have to take a
pooper real fast yeah i uh
i'm kind of having a similar thing you
had i had a little sinus infection and
i'm coming off antibiotics so my stomach
has just been [ __ ] up that pesto [ __ ]
no it's not green like that but it's
like kind of black
way black's not good
well i googled it and it has to do with
um blood and antibiotics leaving your
system but it's not like black black is
no it's not like because if it's black
you definitely need to see a dog
it's not like tar it's like um
it's brown but a little more on the
darker okay okay yeah black means
there's blood in your
system that you're [ __ ] out
that's definitely an urgent issue if
anyone's [ __ ] black oh yeah
chernobyl was hbo that was one of the
greatest shows ever i loved that show
nobody was really good it was amazing
dude you know that's one of the best
shows ever i love that show oh dark by
the way dark on netflix it's a german
show i don't think you guys saw it it's
a sci-fi show i watched the whole thing
i love that show that's awesome i've
seen it it's really good dude oh that
was [ __ ] awesome and i thought they
stick the landing which was really hard
to do because it's like a time travel
show and all these crazy converging
plots they really uh stuck the landing
human fecal matter
all right ready
yeah let me know when you're about three
two oh
just play it three two one
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh poorly i forgot how scared she was
with that
wow what a heartwarming
so heartwarming i want that show you
know
we call it full studio
full studio ladies and gentlemen yeah it
had the full house theme over it but i
figured that get us cleaned so
all right
um
so now we're getting to
some good stuff here fresh and fit as
you guys know actually before we get
into that we are at 35 minutes if we
want to do our other ad well having so
much fun here it's out of control out of
control we have one other sponsor which
is awesome uh curology who you know i
use in love
uh curology is awesome here's how it
works
it is a game-changing custom skin care
made for you specifically by dermatology
providers they create a custom
prescription cream for your specific
goals whether that's tackling acne
clogged pores skin texture dark spots
fine lines or something else you start
by taking a short online quiz about your
skin
and you upload photos close-ups of your
face so they can see what's going on and
if they think it's a good fit if they
think they can help you
they'll ship you your formula right to
your door
by dermatology providers and it even
it's got your name on it it's a real
prescription
um so if basically what they sent me is
they got the dermatology cream they got
the face wash
and the moisturizer and i love all three
of these products i personally think the
face wash and the moisturizer slap super
hard
you know they're really soft and i feel
like
perfectly cleans my skin without
stripping all the oil
and the moisturizer
is really gentle and it feels very
moisturized without making my fin skin
feel oily and
overdone
so i really highly recommend it i mean
who's got time to go to a dermatologist
and do all that
get started with curology just like i
did with a free 30-day trial at
curology.com h3 and just pay five bucks
for shipping and handling for your free
30-day trial that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash h3 to get
started with your free 30-day trial
cancel anytime prescription is subject
to consultation
thank you curology
and i don't want to hear any wise asses
saying that my allergies my allergic
reactions from that
i've been using this [ __ ] for like a
whole year okay so stop it
we love our sponsors
i could see it happening right stop it
people were gonna say that well i had
the thought because i had heard that it
got really bad over the weekend and
honestly i stopped using it because i
was so paranoid i just wanted to figure
out what it was so i haven't been using
any products like i just soaked my body
i don't wash my face sure sure yeah but
i was just picturing your face all
puffed up and like red and then coming
in here and doing a cure yeah would have
been really [ __ ] funny
but now you look you honestly look fine
it's a weird rash because you can't see
it but like i can feel my skin is super
coarse and itchy yeah yeah
well anyway thank you to our sponsors so
fresh and fit uh you guys know them you
love them they're one of my favorite
people to [ __ ] on lately because they're
just
they're actually terrible people
toxic
lunatics
and uh
well that's fit fresh i don't know i
think fresh is just he has he's had a
lobotomy or something you know what uh
got pointed out on our subreddit this
weekend and kind of blew my mind what uh
fresh
on instagram has like 10 times the
amount of followers is fit
interesting
does he have engagement on his posts
what's the engagement uh
comparison it's better it's better
what the f wait send me the links i
gotta i could definitely see a universe
where that guy in real life is
you know fine whereas the other guy is
just so annoying that nobody wants to
interact with him like a multiverse type
thing
prince of barbados coconuts and barbados
is that a reference to us
master networker no he's from barbados
[Music]
why are people following this guy he
doesn't even talk
it's a good question because i was
thinking maybe he has some prior
i was wondering if he had some kind of
prior
fame yo he drives that car or did you
just stand in front of it
it's hard to say
money can't buy you happiness but it can
buy you a lamborghini wrote
wrote on my gold board five years ago i
wanted to buy a lamborghini now i own
two well there you go the [ __ ] and
another one on the way what the [ __ ]
okay you don't need three okay you don't
need three lamborghinis i could just
point out that they charged 30 on cameo
for the both of them how's this guy
affording lamborghini that's what i'm
saying
they're hustling for five dollars a pop
that might not even be minimum wage
but that's what what does this guy do on
the side he obviously has something on
the side he does
uh perhaps it looks like he hangs out at
the fountain blue that's all i'm seeing
well this is proof of anything that you
don't need to be smart to be successful
i don't know his his bio screens both
followers everyone with a bio like that
but the engagement is just so real
people oh yeah we got to see the
comments more than the likes i feel like
all right let me so this one has 106.
bro can you not yeah
so
[ __ ] hard uh
there's verified people just everyone's
doing fire emojis that's pretty
suspicious
fraud and scam once again
all these wait don't show that he cut
away oh thank you ian i'm reading dude
can you not damn bro
uh fraud and scam
that's what he's calling him scamming
once again all those girls are fake
holograms and the cars rented
i called the dealership wait what oh
that's a joke about me i think
this is very interesting i don't know
what's going on with this dude
you got the rewind sound effect dude
so then where's so this guy sits there
and doesn't even talk and he's got three
lamborghinis so where's the main guys
okay here so here is a fit
he has way less followers like four
times less followers isn't that
interesting
huh
wow
look at these pixies posting though what
a nerd
damn dude fresh is the mastermind it's
like uh
he is
he's actually the brains behind the
operation yeah he's like kevin spacey
and uh usual slush look at this look at
this
this i mean they straight up didn't they
straight up were like calling him dumb
on his own show yeah yeah yeah
interesting
wait what was he up to here once upon a
time when i got canceled off youtube
this would be my linkedin picture to
apply for feminist activists
all right
huh i don't know it barely made sense
whoa that's interesting
huh
fresh is the brains
today it is wednesday
i doubt i doubt
today is wednesday my dude it's monday
but we'll let it slide man we'll let it
slide man it is wednesday man it sure is
buddy
wait look at fit's comments are they
good
which one it fits if it's the main whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa wait wait wait wait
wait
okay now now i've noticed something
really odd
this post with 5 000 likes has 11 000
comments
whoa yeah
that hairline in your profile pic is a
lie but you tend to do that so i guess
it's like all people [ __ ] on them
yuck yeah
why do women continue to date men after
seeing this
the fact that instagram verified proves
existence of the patriarchy
someone said uh this is why you're
single your personality plus how you
look is damning
the fact that you feel you have to say
inflammatory things to emulate having a
personality
so he's getting absolutely bodied in the
comments meanwhile fresh everybody's
like looking good king
so wait wait wait
he has twice as many comments as he does
likes i think he posted that photo like
right when he first went viral when you
first heard about him and everyone
started i see but they all have a
shitload of comments so they just came
to harass him
i guess so this one has a shitload of
comments too
you're disgusting sad little man wow
but then if you go to
freshest
it's just fire emoji and you're the king
so if you go to fred maybe he's just
been deleting mean comments because i
get the feeling he doesn't have better
things to do
see these 100 comments 160 120
200
you know what i mean
and it's all fire emojis this is
interesting
isn't this interesting crown
to go bro no hate there's no hate well
anyway
uh they recently called into an
australian show talk show
trying to spout their [ __ ] about how
uh women having instagram is cheating
and about how men should be able to
sleep around but women can't
and the australian host just absolutely
dunked on them this clip went viral and
tick-tock it has almost a million likes
men are territorial with their women
it's been that way since the beginning
of you don't own us in a relationship so
we can post what we want
if you have an insecurity with that
that's on you finish let me finish you
i'm letting you finish but every time i
let you finish you're literally cutting
me off right now
okay go go go i'm explaining to you he's
like listen
i'm this is hyperbole but it's like
listen i just think that all jews should
die no let me finish let me finish hold
on don't cut me off
i was just saying that i think we should
round up all the jews in the world don't
don't cut me off
let me just finish my point maybe you'll
come around to it so i hate the jews yes
keemstar we know that
[Laughter]
how men view relationships you might not
like it it might hurt your feelings you
might say i'm not a piece of property
whatever but with all due respect your
feelings this is oh what a ben shapiro
king wow with all due respect
i mean with all due respect uh you're
going to die alone
you know yeah
you're feeling so bad
you're actually misogynistic and
egotistical and it's a kind of a concern
the way you view relationships like you
have ownership of women men are
territorial women
this wasn't the viral one
there was one where he told him to [ __ ]
off and
and close the call yeah i guess
that was the one that i saw that was
going viral yeah yeah
three million likes okay that wow
wow okay
men and women are not the same women
like attention men want sex so my thing
is a man is capable of having sex with
other women while still loving his girl
the same you're actually saying that in
a relationship it's okay for men to go
and explore other options but we have to
be happy with you and not explore
options absolutely close on your end
open on my end and i think this should
be honest between the two
you can't just go
throwing that thing around i spoke i
spoke today i spoke to jan i spoke to
dan belserian
i'm sick of you asking to finish your
long boring we answers that are the same
answer every time we ask you a question
even dan belserian last week you told me
to my face so [ __ ] what clown here
you are on the show i can turn you off
as well just turn these clowns off see
your fellas grow up bring us back when
you're 30 and you've got a half a brain
you're not running around being led by
your own dicks bye-bye see you later
turn them off
yeah exactly men and women are not the
same and he's right these guys are like
a broken record i mean it's like they i
i don't know how this is entertaining
because they basically make the same
point women are emotional men are uh men
are sexual they we should be able to
[ __ ] as many women as one they need to
not do anything it's like the same
shtick over and over it's almost like a
cultish affirmation for incels
but yeah
he got it right on the head there
um also i will say that fresh and fit
have yet to comment on their good friend
cobra being arrested for human
trafficking
more on that later
yeah more on that later cobra may have
made talked about me on his show yeah
you know his he goes by cobra uh
taint cobra tate oh taint actually i i
think he's cobra taint
which is what you just said but like the
taint you know under the balls right
yeah the pain
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah dan [ __ ] me up i'm sorry man it
is wednesday man it is
isn't it
barbados
so shout out i mean these guys
absolutely bodied him i find it
interesting he they he went on their
show by himself why are you so scared of
me and you know you called in there's no
roller
yeah they're still upset that we like
kind of just said [ __ ] off to them so
but
they can call in why i have open door
for them oh do you that's what i said
last time i said they can call in
anytime they want
live or planned or scripted you
literally just give me the time and call
me and i will talk to you
okay
i mean he's dodging
he's dodging we literally message him
anytime this comes up and say come on
the show and he's like oh he's always
making all these excuses i'm like oh i
need to do this i need to do that
here here's this co oh he did he just
write this this was on friday's episode
wow he wrote he left a comment yeah
you guys are still taking shots while
ducking the debate you challenged us to
lol bro i'm begging you call in any time
we literally been messaging you non-stop
call in calling stop talking [ __ ] and
just call in stop being a [ __ ] or maybe
he just got whipped so hard by the
australians that he doesn't want to show
his face
why are you willing to face them by
yourself and not me just come on you
little [ __ ] boy
call in any time right now if you're
watching call in right now
okay
bring ro bring the whole pack of rolos
not just one bring the whole damn pack
let's call it thursday that would be a
banger bring copper tate bring
bring the whole crew bring your pokemon
cards
all your groups and gaffs
man all those four guys you get a fresh
fit cobra taint
and rolo tony brown town together walk
into a bar
all the women cover all the women cover
their drinks
cobra taint fresh and fit
and uh rolo tony walk into a bar all the
women's uh drinks turn purple from the
uh
date
our detector
um
yeah i don't know why this guy's
literally dodging me so hard just call
in please
you don't think i want to have a viral
moment like they just did you see how
they owned you at 3 million likes
i'll let you talk
you know
don't make me show the dms bro i'll show
the dm's how we're like come on any
condition whatever you want just come on
that's it
i'll show the dms bro don't make don't
make me go that far
literally the last time we messaged him
i was like just come on any condition by
yourself with rollo tonight with
corporate date with fresh i'll even do
it by myself
no response
but what do you want
so just respond bro
there's a hunger for this character to
come back
yeah exactly
there is a hunger for this character to
come back
can you believe these cowards l-o-l shut
up
people want to see the dms i'm not going
to go there just yet but i will
if he keeps lying and saying that we're
ducking him
if he tries that [ __ ] again
you know what i'm saying
well anyway there's more just saying
that's refreshing though to see them
getting so humiliated
i mean the problem though is that the
reason he's like this is because his mom
used to make him tuck his dick back when
he was a kid so i don't know if
humiliate him this is the right way to
fix him but he might already be broken
but that's how people like this is how
he gets like this
mom made him tuck his dick back and
pretend he was a girl shame
his mom used to mangina him when he was
eight shame which is horrible
shame you know
can you move this jake paul thing under
the cobra taint because i want to do
that next
yeah okay so cobra taint
and his brother cr uh christian
tristan tristan the guys who we talked
about recently they are
you know human fecal matter they're red
pillars
uh
cobra taint has said that basically he
tricks girls into
doing a webcam business for him
and he keeps the money
uh he's and he was just arrested for
human trafficking the u.s embassy
reached out to him he lives in
i think it's romania romania romania
reached out to him and they're like yo
this guy is holding an american citizen
hostage and making her do
webcams
and uh he got raided by the police in
romania
for human trafficking um
and i guess he's out on bail did you see
who got him out
it's in the discord
oh my god so like yeah this makes sense
this is who got him out
so this actually you know let's go
my great client here cobra taint was
charged was charged with two counts of
human trafficking he has priors of human
trafficking and uh essay
he had was under the influence of 20
drugs he actually killed two people
while in
drug induced uh
psychosis and i'm happy to report here
that my great client cobra taint uh got
off with no jail time let's go
by the way this guy's the best i love
this lawyer i was giggling about over
the weekend and going back and watching
it
look at that can we are
we trying to contact him ian
we're on it we're working on it oh yeah
i want him
zero jail time baby let's go
are you happy with the results covertain
i am very happy with the results i am
going back to my uh
to my webcam damn damn with some water
some bubbling water
you're a [ __ ] if you don't drink the
bubbling water he said water how did you
say water
anyway here they are talking about me
there's a guy with a really big podcast
there's a guy with a really big podcast
okay who who actually genuinely spoke a
ton of [ __ ] about me yeah yeah salted me
loads saying like i'm in cell and i
don't get [ __ ] oh that's the worst
that's not the worst thing i said about
you bro i called you a human trafficker
okay saying you're an intel that doesn't
get [ __ ] is
probably the lightest thing i said and
the fact that you perceive that as the
biggest
insult is [ __ ] crazy
holy [ __ ] dude
jesus christ this guy
on the left said i don't get [ __ ] okay
show me
no no no no i'm married bro well i'm not
i'm not in the getting [ __ ] game
i have two kids but like also i don't
care about like how much [ __ ] i get
that that doesn't define my worth as a
person
i can't believe that's the thing he
identified
as the as the thing that insulted him
the most
these men they they
he really measures his worth by how much
[ __ ] he gets and that's so disturbing
oh my god this man is literally a
caveman
i think we found the missing link
holy [ __ ]
oh you're not in tim and don't act like
you're not intimidated by this stance
boy
you know i look you know i look good
yeah hell yeah
no tristan he actually was saying this
guy doesn't know about girl that guy
that guy he look he looks like he tries
to make best friends with kids at the
park he definitely does he drives a
creepy black dog you literally kidnap
kids at the park that's your [ __ ] job
i mean it's interesting that you say i'm
looking for kids at the park you're
literally a human trafficker
um
you were just raided by the police for
for kidnapping people
wasn't she like 18 or 19 or something i
don't know basically children
but dude you
why don't you talk about
what hap does did you watch this whole
thing anyone did he talked about maybe
he and zach both yeah did he talk about
getting raided no not one not the part
you're gonna call me out and ignore the
fact you were just raided by the
romanian swat team for human trafficking
bro no wonder he keeps saying that the
worst thing i said about him is that he
gets no [ __ ] because he doesn't want to
mention the part that he's a [ __ ]
criminal
yeah you would ignore the other [ __ ] i
was saying
hey bro here's an idea get a shirt that
fits you why you got the oh you know
what i'm saying also he needs a better
microphone and same with fresh and fit
his audio [ __ ] dude
there you have it
zach probably the worst crime do you
concur dan
i mean oh yeah the worst thing he's ever
done
by far yeah
but if you're doing a podcast you better
get your audio sorted
this is my favorite thing maybe that
we've watched
and why i love this [ __ ] oh my god
go ahead cobra subscription to skip the
ag extra premium yeah extra preview he
looks like it's a kind of guy oh thank
you for ice cream don't tell your mom
it's one of them
he supposedly has a big podcast i had no
idea who this guy was right so someone
sent me this link i looked it up there's
this heifer this out shaped dude and
then there's some other really out
shaped chick and then i realized
obviously they're just jealous because
they're both obese no he's the thing did
he say wait did he say there was a hot
chick
he said i i think out of shape i think
yeah oh
okay yeah offend him can i defend him
for half a second
if i was him wait someone wanted to
defend me
listen to him listen i'd hate us too or
you i don't know if he came in post of
us for you i don't i don't watch his
[ __ ] channel i don't watch fat dudes
what the [ __ ] what i listen to i don't
watch fat dudes i
i don't watch fat dudes
i don't [ __ ] with dumb fat dudes bruv
i tell you what kung fu panda i don't
[ __ ] with the with that fat jack black
will will ferrell a little bit
overweight don't watch his movies
these guys are bright man really bright
i hate you of course he does
of course he does don't get mad at the
dude
he's clearly lonely he's wearing [ __ ]
baggy ass shorts let me tip was he
american he looks [ __ ] amazed dressed
as american i'm in my tailored ten
thousand dollar suits without a geeky
hat on i haven't got a pedo mustache i
got all the women i got money i got the
bugatti i got the jet it's true but no
of course he hates us but it's just an
amazing lack of self-awareness for
somebody like that it's actually almost
an impressive so are you guys gonna
mention you got raided by the swat team
for human trafficking or you're just
gonna ignore that part he's fat
dude
what the [ __ ] they never mentioned that
[ __ ] bro
you all need to mention that before you
talk about me
i just love the fact that they have to
bring up their their self-worth because
they're so insecure about this yeah yeah
i have a ten thousand dollar suit i'm
six foot four wings
i have a jet and a bugatti it's like
cool dude good for you in all honesty
their insecurity is scary like oh it's
i've heard stuff about them in the past
like trying to doxx people i don't know
if it's legit or no everyone knows right
definitely
i'm glad they live in in romania yeah
you know
but they're obviously very bad dudes
they
kidnap people they're criminals so
you know whatever
it is kind of it's fun too because like
not that not that he even has a point
with this or that it matters but if they
actually knew anything about you i mean
you are also very wealthy
you
live in los angeles they live in romania
no offense to our romanian fans but it's
a little los angeles rich versus
romanian rich there is a difference
there yeah and people who only admire
money saying you have a creepy black van
which has a rolls royce
it is a rolls royce
no i am not that makes you better than
them or any of many but it's just it's
ironic that they're bringing that up
you know they probably don't know
anything about you so no i'm not poor
and and obviously i don't take offense
to that i think it's funny also what's
interesting about my money is that i
made it by uh not human trafficking
people so right that's a bonus for me i
think
very very good bonus you know what i'm
saying yes like it's all on the books
i've paid taxes on everything i didn't
kidnap anyone and force them into doing
webcam stuff like that so it's good
money it's clean money
but i don't have a i don't have a
bugatti
yo so i i think that what they're trying
to say
when they say i look like i'd be at a
playground they're trying to say stay
off our turf
we don't need no competition around here
we're we recruit young we you know they
say with models and baseball they try to
find them young
well there you have it stay off our turf
buddy get off a slide man you can't go
on it
that's awesome
yeah
love it
lack of self-awareness for someone like
that to look at someone like me who's as
accomplished as i am with every genetic
gift god can possibly bestow
except in accepting intelligence i mean
except rational thought
accept any moral compass which is
important by the way to live in society
you have to have some morals
every this is god's chosen uh champion
except [ __ ] hair on your head sorry
but i'm just saying
i mean hairline check you know
just saying just saying he said got
every genetic
you know just saying go okay
he doesn't get women like i don't know
if he's just dilute like did i even ever
say they don't get women why do they
even identify that as a i could see you
having said that yeah i'd have to go
back and watch but
i mean of course they have sex uh who
cares though
you know
i mean especially if it's like with
michaela peterson
i have relationships with women
i wonder if they did eat like a steak
like relating to the [ __ ] or you meet
in the middle
[Laughter]
eating a rob big ass [ __ ] t-bone
it's actually an incredible it's
actually almost an impressive level of
dilution yeah well let me ask a question
let me ask a question to people like him
who will say [ __ ] like that about people
like us
men complain all the time oh women just
like guys with money women only like
guys who are six foot plus women only
like guys who blah blah everything you
guys complain about women only like
describes me
so i never said any of those things bro
i'm married
i i never come i have no idea what to
talk about i never complain about any of
that stuff bro i really don't care
i mean that's that's you're not a high
value male he he makes it sound like i
was like it's not fair i don't get any
[ __ ] and these tall guys are [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] and i'm just so bitterly
married for 10 years with two kids
well these guys got all the [ __ ]
if the women aren't [ __ ] me who are
they [ __ ] you
the short poor guys
like money women if you're six foot tall
oh the tapes don't get laid
i'm short
[Laughter]
okay well
don't expect them to watch the whole
position short and poor baby that's me
yeah
how the [ __ ] do you connect those two
things and make them make sense i'm six
foot [ __ ] four 110 kilograms i got my
[ __ ] muscles i got my cars i got my
big-ass house i got the jacuzzi
aquito would you like to come on a date
and drink some champagne sitting in the
jacuzzi with me no i want to date the
fat guy with a podcast who's sure
i'm actually sure that a lot of women
would prefer to date me
i'm not saying that as a flex just
because you're like a sas who's like
creepy and violent and scary and like
unhinged lunatic
and obviously not a good partner and so
like yeah there are there are different
kinds of women in the world and and the
one that i would pursue is one like ela
who is looking for someone with
substance and stability and uh and a
levity and a sense of humor and stuff
like that and uh that's the kind of
woman that i would want to date and be
with anyway so
it's just find it like this is where
these guys they they put everyone in
these holes like they say all men are
the same all women are the same and i
just don't know how you go through your
life living like so simplistic uh
simplistically like that
but it really you know it's interesting
because these guys could do coaching and
it really shows you what they think
about the people that pay them for
advice because they go you're short
you're fat you'll nev you're you're
pathetic you'll never you're not you
don't have what i have so like what are
you doing bothering taking people's
money and coaching them if they're not
six foot four and rich because
apparently if you're just fat you
shouldn't even exist
maybe that's the coaching
he's like here here's how tall are you
here's the questionnaire we'll start
with the question here under six foot
just kill yourself this is gonna get the
remember we looked the leg lengthening
surgery oh
they like break your legs and then you
spend three years healing to gain like
you can add like four inches no you can
get bigger than that
also maybe
maybe that's the advice i'm gonna get
that's that uh surgery and come step to
them what's up
what's up now
who are they [ __ ]
so i i i have not i have genuinely not
watched the episode all i know is he was
insulting me i actually tried to watch
the episode to do like an important one
bro you know what the worst thing about
him the worst thing about him is not
only he's a mouth breather yeah because
probably because he's yeah yeah he's
literally the other way but worse is
he's not even intelligent he's not
compendiuous he can't even do as we do
he can't even speak quickly so he's one
of those guys who does the podcast is
like
hey yeah so
this this
this guy's got a youtube channel
i don't want to do it that's a spot on
impression i gotta say i nailed it i
don't want to do this but can you just
do me a favor and sh how many views does
this uh one have because they're master
podcasters right so they should be doing
good
as opposed to me who is a horrible
talker a slow talker a mouth breather
all that
um let's check their views here
oh [ __ ] we just got good news
yeah eli just sent this in the chat
that's the website one right i oh yeah
i'm telling you yo wait hold on we just
got breaking news
hold on let me get this alright i just
got a mail too
okay breaking news guys
uh
am i under that's the website one right
yeah it is breaking news ryan kavanaugh
has just lost another lawsuit against us
[Applause]
ryan kavanagh he first lost the first
lawsuit against us the tortious
interference one took the l now i'm
proud to announce that his effort to
remove does ryan kavanaugh look like
harvey weinstein has failed
the court has ruled that does right
kavanaugh look like harvey weinstein
as a legitimate institution it cannot be
removed we are not impersonating him and
there you have it the website shall
remain and all of its glory
hallelujah that's two down baby
two to go how about you suck these
[ __ ] nuts ryan you [ __ ] loser [ __ ]
hope that pillow fighting championship
goes well for you
hey ryan do they have pillow fights in
prison because i'm pretty sure you're
gonna be going there soon
for fraud and stuff
nothing related to you natalie
department
say that again ryan
an inappropriate relationship with a 14
year old natalie department
oh yeah he's going to jail oh yeah
so ryan i hope you're watching this uh
if you just watch anything it's suck
this [ __ ] tiny jewish cog you [ __ ]
and shout out to brad the bowl who's
giving it to his wife good every night
ladies and gentlemen gave it up to brad
you know he looks good he knows how to
lay the d and she is very satisfied
thanks to brad the bull
hey ryan how does it feel to lose you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you're never gonna
take this down
suck my [ __ ] dick
you're a giant piece of [ __ ]
you're used to suing people and getting
your way not today you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i hope you're crying and feeling sad you
pathetic loser that's two down four to
go the website stays up because let's
face it ryan it's free speech two down
two to go two down two to go okay i was
like are there two more that i don't
know what did i say you said two down
four to go i'm not gonna go down two to
go
suck my [ __ ] dick
yeah
hey
yeah no i know it's a it's
yeah no it's okay
so ryan you can suck my dick
hey ryan you could suck my dick hey ryan
you can suck my dick my big fat juicy
tiny dick it's juicy but it's small
you can fit it in your mouth all right
you can ride this dick
you little [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] hey
my [ __ ] dick
let's kick it up right ryan is a piece
of [ __ ] said what
let's kick it off ryan is a piece of
[ __ ] throw your hands in the air throw
your hand throw your hands in the air
ryan is a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
oh
come on
[Music]
let's throw it up
you know because you're a piece of [ __ ]
damn let's go to the website everybody
to celebrate
type ryan cavanaugh on the google
this website's not going anywhere
and that is brian cowell as a force of
me he sure is harvey he sure is a force
of nature
suck my [ __ ] dick now a lot of people
said going up against a billionaire not
a great idea ethan but you know what i
say to them
[ __ ] ryan kavanagh nobody will ever
infringe on my right to free speech i
will always defend myself against all
[ __ ] odds against all reason i will
stand up to do the right thing and ryan
you're taking the l
l
you should change your name to l
you change your name to elion
lavana
that's his the his names with elves in
the front
elion lavana wow
got him what the [ __ ] you that was a
piece of [ __ ]
lying kavanaugh
lying ryan
so this one ryan ryan ryan ryan so this
one we can't um
pursue legal fees on but the
the one we won last time we can and we
are
and the two remaining is the copyright
one and the uh defamation one
which i'm feeling good about and those
ones we can pursue legal fees on
so i think ryan's going to take off i'm
just feeling good you know that's two
out of four
and you know when you sue someone four
times and let's just say hypothetically
he loses all four of them that's a not a
good look that looks like legal
harassment like and you know i mean
god that guy sucks so bad
i mean what a [ __ ] [ __ ] he is
right
yeah he sucks
ryan ryan
uh well at least his wife is getting a
good
you know
so why did someone say this isn't about
you ethan it's about love
is that a joke
i don't know
well anyway um
this is awesome i'm super happy
lion ryan lavanot
lion ryan levana
yeah it is legal harassment i mean
there's stress straight up
oh wait ti tate's live chatting no this
is from the video we're just reacting to
this was his live chat
this is the best comment from his live
chat look
he has tourette's laughing face like
what a [ __ ] loser
he's a loser he was born with tourette's
wow
and then the other one ela just gave ten
dollars by the way oh thank you generous
queen to just write l's over and over
again
another one
uh
uh he is jew he is a jew and pro-israel
i'm not pro-israel
where does that come from i mean the jew
part is probably the more telling
right element of that comment i get the
feeling what they're getting at there
yeah
i get the feeling that uh these guys
aren't too interested in the uh
politics of jews
go on keemstar i'm not i'm scared how
you're gonna end that one death to all
jews
but there you go keemstar said i was
going to go to jail
keemstar hates the jews and so far we're
looking pretty good i'm feeling really
good i'm really happy the website's
staying up you know yo
this is the best one yet that you just
found b
this is this is quite the engine he uses
his brain to pay for big macs that's why
it's so slow
what the [ __ ] epic epic own right there
what
it's almost
that's great news i'm i'm very happy it
would have honestly been such a tragic
blow if that website went down but i
think he knew that it was a long shot
it's just a pathetic another pathetic
attempt to try to drain me of my funds
and just give in but that ain't ever
going to happen do you understand that
ryan i will spend every [ __ ] dime i
have
uh to defend my rights
okay
this is america ryan last i checked and
it means something to be an american
hasta la vista baby
it's really true this guy sues everybody
for anything and it usually works i mean
he called us a toy podcast once a while
ago how's this toy podcast doing for you
ryan
anyway
can he be uh another comment pull that
one up dan sure and you know it's gonna
be fire
when you got an anime profile he says
that guy makes his staff wear masks
while they film their podcasts as well
i mean
we did for like a week when we had a
covet scare that seems reasonable yeah
yeah
and like at the height of the lockdown
when it was basically yeah when all
businesses were shut down but we had an
exemption for being entertainment
yo
this dude doesn't even drink sparkling
water bro
walter sparkling water
that wasn't baffled
his viewers would agree oh wait did can
you find their views because i did want
to do that
73k sorry that's this podcast has 73k
views
okay i have to admit that's more than i
thought they would be having i would
have thought like 12k yeah yeah
um that's more than i expected but i
don't know if i need to pull up my
podcast because uh
i'm just gonna say this
clearly people like listening to me talk
more
than you guys
just saying
the numbers don't lie boys just saying
and i'm not here to toot my own horn but
come on now
just saying somebody said real cute toy
podcast wasn't it
wasn't that what kavanaugh said about
you yeah that's what i just said he said
when he sent his threatening instagram
message to me he said i don't know what
you think you're doing with your toy
podcast but you're messing with real
things here it has real consequences
yeah right
yeah so here's the expectation of what
uh cobra taint does and here's the
reality he's actually on the school bus
oh no
he he like i said he grooms he gets them
young
and just like a model scout uh
you know for his webcam thing
type the type of person who watches that
kind of guy for entertainment is that
kind of guy his brain is so slow he
can't even speak quickly
what are you talking about
i got stuff to do right
what
[Laughter]
i honestly can't even say anything
they're just shouting
he's poor he's fun
he can't talk fast
since when is talking fast uh
and favorable attribute
talking fast and never can be
contextually but you know
it's not inherently
talk fast
you putting that on your resume or
something real fast
the fast guy if i sit down i want to
okay tell me i mean i don't do i didn't
do a line before my show like you guys
clearly did
he doesn't speak particularly fast
either he just is loud
he seems to be speaking at a fairly
regular pace i would say we gotta
remember this is the guy that doesn't
have time to cook
said cooking's for poor people right
right
or rich people actually
cooking's for morons
and rich people
because they have the time
let's go
i mean people that shout like this i
think are insecure in what they're
saying so they shout to make it seem
more interesting
what information insult me get it over
with so i'm sitting there and i'm just
seeing
anyway
look at this
youtube i was like i can't even watch
this it's [ __ ] awful like you need
something something super rare i ain't
even mad i don't even mad of course
people like that you know what if people
like that didn't hit us we're doing
something wrong
um the biggest own of all is the fact
that they don't mention being arrested
for human trafficking
basically that's that's the biggest own
i mean that's checkmate right there
we cut it short but they went on they
said some nasty things about ela yeah
that would even want to show why let's
watch it that's good stuff
what do they say i mean it's good let's
come on no either secure about herself
she's not gonna make these bozos make
her feel bad
okay i'll send it
trust me i i only want it for the
entertainment value um
ela gets this [ __ ] all the time she's
very secure as am i
they're not going to make her feel bad i
just want to know how low these guys go
to basically avoid saying that we were
arrested for human trafficking
let's see
i mean at least she's with me by by
choice you know at least my wife chooses
to be with me unlike your [ __ ]
partners you shackle in a small room
make them webcam like i try to get a
woman to willfully stay with you for
more than six months bro see how that
works out
oh wait hang on
should we do that so this is it oh god
she looks so beautiful like you're gonna
be stretching to try to make it sound
like she's not gorgeous
okay so let's see let's see how they do
oh seriously
seriously
pow pow mister you can't even steal that
guy's wife because we cannot be seen
with a woman of that caliber in the
compound but or in public what if she's
in the compound
i know what that means
holds the camera yo if i if i was next
first of all ela's gorgeous everybody
knows that
he's if i was dating or like uh
tell what's a beautiful woman's name
nobody can think of one what the [ __ ]
i mean of a celebrity yeah
kim kardashian no that's not a good one
i knew you wouldn't accept that's the
person
what's your name [ __ ] the girl who
was
do
if i was next to doula lipa they'd be
like dude i can never be caught with the
girl of this caliber like no matter how
beautiful the girl is they'd be like oh
no she's the worst looking girl i've
ever seen sorry ela's objectively
gorgeous take the l [ __ ] you know what
i think we might fire
scott adam's wife and hire ethan's wife
should we do that so this is it this is
why we don't get girls and this is his
wife let me tell you something ethan i
would rather
sleep in a bed by myself every night for
the rest of my life
than marry a woman who looked like that
that's right
so first
first of all you have to find someone
who wants to marry you first
which i have a feeling is going to be
very difficult for you guys
but again
yeah do a lipa would be like this is
disgusting what a [ __ ] fat
b word
even if i didn't get girls i'm doing
better than you that's the negative
girls that's minus girls
christ i'm sorry but like no matter how
hard they try to pretend like ella's
ugly she's gorgeous and you can't
you can't even
nobody's even believing this i mean
she's not
she looks great you foul son but you
know you sort your life out you know
what like
scott i love the fact that christina
moves my cam whilst adam's watching the
kids
so what i'm thinking of doing is tristan
hear me out okay what have i got two
moving cams okay
okay and they can both move like i don't
want this girl in my house
ethan's wife scott adam's wife both are
moving my cameras and then what i'll do
is i'll tandem put them on who's he
talking about scott um is that another
guy that got beef with something i'm not
sure about that it seems like it so
they're talking about kidnapping ela and
putting her in webcam slavery
oh nice it seems oh by the way
cheers
sparkling water oh classy
can i get a soda water so i don't look
poor and and miserable please somebody
yeah
yeah so they're saying basically i'm
gonna kidnap your wife
put her in the webcam and put her in uh
uh human trafficking slavery
uh
awesome
so i actually moved the needle there
same screen because i'm done that's what
i'm about to do
i'll miss a producer
that's what's happened to the next show
two steady cams two wives every single
time someone annoys me i take their wife
we had another steady cam to set up
until it just gets ridiculously large
the point can no longer get in the room
and they have to have 50 little boxes of
moving cameras and no one understands
what's going on you can label them and
i've been labeled and i just sit there
just talk about everyone's wives i own
as they steadily move the cameras before
we go to my bedroom for a steady hand
job super steady
what i don't even know what the [ __ ] is
on about
i stepped out to get a drink for a
minute and i'm totally lost as to what
he's talking about every white he steals
he's going to add another steadicam to
his video setup for the podcast
what's the i don't get the joke yeah i
don't get it maybe i'll go back i also
think he said he owns
like people or did he mean
yeah he just got raided by the romanian
police for owning people that was the
problem right that's actually the crime
you did commit that you're not
mentioning on the show
i was going to say this but since
they're making fun of it it looks like
tristan is wearing a hair piece
oh you think so no
something does not look natural there
well if that's his brother that hair you
can't explain that hair with this head
something's going on like this guy is
bald as [ __ ] he looks like a [ __ ]
hard-boiled egg dude
he's going to kill me now for saying
that but yeah he's coming to you next
boy
she looks like no i don't know and full
respect to to my girl out there kate and
jenner she doesn't look like caitlyn
jenner she looks like straight up bruce
from the 1970s i'm not bruce wayne dude
you guys are just saying [ __ ] like
come on
try harder to insult her dude it's just
like ridiculous no no no it's rude bruce
jenner
jeez that's his wife that's his wife you
know we don't get girls that's another
guy we always talk about who's the guy
who puts the dildos up his bomb and
talks about being really important and
thinks he's in charge well this guy this
guy probably does do that no of course
he does this but it's a different guy
and then and then he's uh what's his
name uh the bum dildo man the one who
[ __ ] i think they're done i don't know
what they're on about but i get the idea
pretty much it
oh no
no here's another comment by the same
guy this is the same guy who said i'm a
jew and i'm pro-israel right yeah oh man
this guy sai ed ethan has a very strong
bond with susan ceo of youtube be
careful guys it's a very strong bond
you guys are tight i think that's more
jewish conspiracy [ __ ] oh yeah shout out
saeed ed
who's
who's a
clearly black pilled af wait one of
their own commenters said that maybe
oh maybe he's onto something
nice wig tristan
interesting yo tristan you have a hair
piece that do you know what that means
like first of all no hate okay but i'm
allowed to make fun of this guy's hair
piece for the very basic fact that he
talks about how they have all the
genetic blessings and their perfect
human specimens but tristan
if that's true why do you glue a [ __ ]
skunk to your head
like imagine this guy who thinks he's
god's gift to the world
going to the the gluer and then they
have to peel it off
his head is bald as a [ __ ]
hard-boiled egg and then they got a they
got to clean his bald head and then add
glue and meanwhile he's like i'm god's
perfect specimen as they glue a [ __ ]
rug to his head
i see other people saying they agree
that it looks like a hairpiece
i mean
i gotta say hairpieces are pretty
amazing i would consider if i was bald
i've seen them some that look really
good but i would probably do the hair
transplant or maybe he has no [ __ ]
hair you can't transplant if you have if
you're as bald as they are
oh there's probably ways i mean no you
or you could take it from your ass i
guess
but usually you need some hair on the
back of the head right to transplant i
guess maybe yeah
i have
you know romania is fairly close to
turkey which is famous for doing those
hair transplants so maybe he just popped
over
you know hassan's always joking about
how it's the hair transplant capital of
the world they do a lot of um
plastic surgeries in turkey if i recall
do they yeah that's right
they just have some kind of thing there
they're great at it so there you go i
mean
you know people saying dan thoughts i i
don't i don't i don't want a hairpiece
you rock it bro you're comfortable
you're paul you're yeah you're proud
but clearly they're jealous of my
hairline and it shows you can always
tell
you know i have an impeccable hairline
and uh that brings out the worst in some
people yeah
it's true that all my worst enemies are
balding or receding it is very
interesting
but i love my bald uh i love my bald
boys out there
ball brethren my balls
my boys and balls
someone said he's too toxic for hair
that's an interesting point
i love that hairpiece though tristan
beautiful
tristan wig
so there you go i got enough of these
clowns but you know like i said the
biggest own of all is that they don't
mention basically 95 of what i was
talking about is how they were arrested
right and they somehow don't they
somehow missed all that i just saw the
part where i said they don't get girls
apparently
well you were talking too slow maybe if
you picked up the pace a little bit come
on
[Music]
okay here this one's for you so i heard
you guys were arrested for human
trafficking is that true or not because
the the american embassy sent a report
to the romanian msp that said there was
a girl being held hostage that's been
disappeared for a few years so is it
true or not that you got arrested by the
romanian swat team for human trafficking
are you out on bail yes or no please
explain
your id
someone says you know that hairpiece
smells like cigarettes and desperation
yeah that would be wild to give that as
a sniff
you guys skip the part where taint asks
his people to find out where you live
might have another cody situation oh
everyone knows where i live come on yeah
wait he said that i want to see that i
didn't see a party i didn't see that i
didn't say that that's pretty maybe
earlier or later in the episode or
something wait if so i actually want
that time stamp i'm really curious to
find it
find out where he lives now that's a
that's a big man
this guy said i don't get girls find out
where he lives that's security right
there if i've ever seen it
oh [ __ ]
oh wait is oliver tree calling in this
week dan uh i think wednesday yeah
someone was saying uh talk about oliver
tree getting his music video ripped off
well he's calling out on wednesday to
talk about it
i was just texting with this guy
that's exciting
um
so there you go let's go wait you guys
didn't see that fit from fresher fits
that he doesn't get women to come
he said that
that i'd like to see
come
that's not surprising
oh this is a good comment talking slow
is low roi that's true
[Laughter]
all right there you have it cobra taint
incorporate the human wig tristan wig
and deborah taylor the human trafficking
brothers
good guys
heroes in the red pill community
um
jack harlow
jack harlow's so everyone's
everyone loves jack harlow i'm actually
not real familiar with his stuff i said
they were talking about this morning i
was like i gotta be honest i have no
idea who jack harlow is and sam
admonished me severely sam you love jack
harlow
i love jack harwa women love jack carlo
why do you love him so much
was he hot women be loving jack you like
his curls he's hot
i like jack harlow he's got sweat that's
swag
i think he's funny i like his music
he is funny actually i've saw an
interview with him though where he is
actually very funny you're right
he he has one song that's real popular
now that's kind of dope
that i see it's like
i'm sex in a
da da
um
yeah it's like a sexy [ __ ] song you
know what i'm talking about sam
yeah that would be called first class
first class oh yeah baby
uh
[ __ ] yeah dude who's hot who who's
hotter right now jack harlow or pete
davidson
you're asking me
uh
ian
that wasn't an option
well the answer is jack carlo
jack harlow that's your boy
i mean yeah he seems like a better
person out and better person to have
he's on some weird [ __ ] i mean we're
talking about it today yeah peter's feet
has gone too far in my opinion yeah
actually jack seems really cool well
adjusted funny i agree i like from what
i've seen i like him but anyway he got
in some deep doo doo
uh he was courtside
at a basketball game and he was started
tweaking with the camera ladies
stop
during a live broadcast
[Applause]
i mean so people got really angry
it's a little childish it's a little
childish but i didn't i didn't think
it's that i i get the impulse
of just being able to do it you know
it's just kind of goofy and shy yeah you
know
but it turned into a whole thing um
said a celtics game
oh and then the person the camera lady
said jack about to get someone fired
and then she responded hi this was me no
bad blood his team apologized after
not much of a drama
turns out but some people were very
angry
on twitter
but there you have it
jack harlow if that's the worst scandal
he's got then god bless him
yeah pretty low-key in the grand scheme
of this is jack harlow by the way if you
don't know
uh
who he is
got a picture of him up
let's see
let me ask you something
look at that picture
you think he's jewish
oh he looks so different without the
beard
is he jewish i have no idea
i i would say
based on what i've seen of him that no i
don't think he is oh wow
is also harlow's not a jewish name is it
not at all
camp he's 24. god lee people are so
young these days camp kim thought he was
no no no okay never mind
why say it
cam just messaged and said i thought he
was
i just thought he was like because i
wrote a comment no it was funny because
i'm like oh is this like he's like jew
baiting no i didn't say that he's not
jubilant no he's actually i said he's
jew-baiting
well here let's get to the butt
he's christian yeah he looks like a guy
he's from kentucky for christ's sake
most people don't even know jews they
think jews are mythological creatures in
[Laughter]
kentucky yeah i had some friends uh in
college who were
like one specifically from spain she had
never met a jew in her life and she was
like whoa you're real i've never met a
jew
well they i guess they killed them all
there in spain from spain and have a
good time there well you're not a troll
man whoa no she was like dude let me
touch you you're real what do you like
i was like what
i just said sleep with one eye open if
i'm nearby because i have a special
blood stream
keep my jew powers up
you know
there's
a lot of places in the world where there
are no jewish people i kind of get it
look there's only like six million of us
and basically we're all in la
new york new york some in florida
and israel and israel that's it i mean
that's it all the jews live in l.a in
the united states you're really not
going to find many jews outside of la
new york i don't know why that is but
that's just what it is
i think i've said this on the show
before and i almost brought it up the
other day when we were talking about
stupid things we believed when we were
kids but
until i was
probably like 11 or 12 until i got to
middle school
i thought
about the world was about 50 50 jewish
people and christian people because yeah
that was the mix at my school in
elementary school yeah there were so
many jewish kids that i thought that was
like the norm totally i had that same
thing i thought there's jews all over
the damn place right
uh love said he's never met a jew before
he came to the us
uh most likely i mean i think most
jewish people in sweden you wouldn't
know because yeah for whatever reason
but you're right there's not a lot
there's not a lot
i think there's like a couple thousand
in sweden that's all
yeah super super wild
yeah
and there's one african pla ethiopia or
somewhere where there's a lot of uh
there's actually a huge tribe of black
jews that are yeah i believe it is in
ethiopia in ethiopia which is kind of
interesting
um
yeah chicago there's a lot of jews in
chicago you're right
but you'd be surprised um how many jews
in the world this really shocked me when
i was a kid oh there's 15 million jews
in the whole world
which is yeah seven billion people which
is small uh 0.19 of the population
to all jews
that's actually more than i thought
here you guys want to look at the jewish
diaspora with me
the diaspora
top places to find jews everyone looking
for jews here's where to look israel
number one
united states number two 5.7 million
france
and it kind of dies off there a little
bit
but wait i want cities
oh well there you have it guys
sweden's on the list
with 15 000
yeah that's probably why it makes sense
45 of the population is jewish in israel
i don't know that's the percentage
globally
oh i see i see 45 of all jews live in
israel i see 40 of all jews live in the
united states it's pretty wild yeah yeah
i mean do you not look for all this [ __ ]
the united states get
it's still one of the best i mean it is
probably the best one of the best places
to live
to practice your you know religion
and not be [ __ ] murdered for it
basically sure any older um jewish
person i've met either lives in boca
raton
or palm springs
there's no oh really palm springs is
happening yeah oh yeah it's happening my
grandmother lives down there
and it's it's
predominantly jewish people they like
the hot when you get old you just were
like anything under like 80 degrees
you're like well because they're a bunch
of old snow birds you know they come
from like chicago or i see a lot of
canadian jews i've met down there
um yeah
well shout out joe carlo who is not
jewish but we still love
regardless uh
zachary whitson just donated 20 and said
going to the courthouse to get divorced
proud to have the boys in my ear while i
walk into the dragon's den look at him
tiger
sometimes you gotta throw in the cards
you want to call in and tell us about it
well if he's walking into the courthouse
he'd probably
live stream it
sometimes you gotta sometimes you gotta
fold the hands you know what i'm saying
i think especially if you have kids you
should try to make it work because
divorce is hard on kids but if you're if
you don't have kids you know there's no
shame in just calling it a day
and depending on how toxic the
relationship is it genuinely might be
better for the kids well if you don't
have kids and you want a divorce you
should get a divorce because you don't
want to
have kids with somebody you don't like
then you end up with cobra taint right
anyway pete davidson
was pictured over the weekend
with a tattoo initialed knscp
which stands for all the names of kim
and kanye's kids kim
north saint chicago
psalm
here's the tattoo
now before we talk about the tattoo we
need to talk about pete's face
what's happening here guys
what kind of what kind of fun is he
getting into that man looks beat
close the trunk
well
we've talked about it before he has some
sort of condition that makes his face
very gaunt like that that's why he's got
the big bags under his eyes so i don't
want to uh
[ __ ] on him too i'm not talking about
that bag on his eyes no i i agree yeah i
was gonna say now that said he looks
pretty blown right there i don't know
that's a long night boy
um
i gotta say
it it could be
that that's what that tattoo is but i
was looking at those pictures if this is
the only evidence
that he did that it's go nah this is
this is so blurry i you can read it you
can see the k
but then
that might be a lowercase n
maybe and then the two next ones k
n the n is very legible
s very legible
c very legible p very legible
i don't know man
there's like four pixels in those
letters it's hard to i feel like i can
see it perfectly
all right before we proceed then let's
do a poll is this are we reading this
right yes or no i mean everybody's
acting as if it is but i i looked around
to see if there were other angles or
other pictures or if they've talked
about it and confirmed it and it just
seems like everybody's just reporting
off this pop one paparazzi photo i think
i
i can read that very clearly
close the trunk close the chime what am
i pulling uh just is this are we
interpreting
does the
tattoo
have
is it say what we think it says
but you know assuming that people agree
which i think they will
yes no or not sure
yeah yeah
yes means it says uh okay does the
tattoo have kim and kanye's kids
initials yeah yeah yeah yes or no or not
sure that's good i'm asking
i mean i find that really weird bro
i'm not down i mean if that is true that
is it's kind of gross very strange and
it's kind of gross that kim would let
him do that i mean
to be honest how long have they been
dating has it even been a year
i mean like six months or something you
don't start and pete davidson he
switches girlfriends like every six
months you don't go tattooing the kids
on you that's [ __ ] weird dude
i would not appreciate that
if i was dating someone
for some reason and they came back with
like my kids tattoos on them i'd be like
no
if if we just started dating you know
yeah hell no
[ __ ] no
well the majority agree
46 say yes
forty percent say not sure fourteen
percent he has already gotten several
kim tattoos so it's on par i mean yeah
and i can under i mean getting a tattoo
of someone you're dating i mean i
wouldn't do that but i get it but yeah
after six months it's already creepy and
weird but the kids that's [ __ ] yeah
that's very strange it's actually [ __ ]
and i guess so after that video he sent
kanye about i'm in bed with your wife
and now this
i think he's
people are saying it's a photoshop i
don't think so
i don't think i don't see anybody saying
it's a photoshop
someone said i feel like he's trying to
make kanye mad i mean yeah what else
would it be right
someone says they've been together eight
months oh yeah and he branded himself
with a kim tattoo
right you know i don't know dude i don't
know i don't like it i'm i find it weird
i don't like it i don't like it keep the
kids out of it
you're a weirdo bro also
listen
no
the kids are the kids nothing against
the kids but
the their names are awful like
that that set of names chicago
saint and psalm it's like
is that not the worst like things to
name your kids ever
let's think about this
well kim comes from a family where they
did [ __ ] names too right they're all
starting with the k so
her mom was marketing them from birth
hey the kkk
perfect
you name your kids chicago chicago don't
you be [ __ ] on chicago i actually
i don't hate it as a name really i don't
hate it song is [ __ ] weird i don't
like song
because then you're just like
you have this weird association forever
saint
saints a little [ __ ] north i like north
i don't think nor so bad i guess north
north's okay
i mean it's a it's an unusual name
kim loves saint
cam loves saint
yeah i love that name i think it's good
i mean i've seen worse names i mean
people saying in the north is dumb too
in the chat i mean it's it's a little
cheesy this is like oh north west
but
anyway here's the other tattoos he has
they're kind of so my girl's a lawyer
is she
even
baby bar
yeah she's not you should have waited on
that one dude jump the gun she's not a
lawyer okay
some people saying north is the worst of
the four
see i kind of agree with that north
seems very
divisive on the on the north i think
psalms the worst one personally i
somber
really bothers me that they name their
kid the name of a city like just chicago
my name is chicago i mean i don't hate
the chicago but it's just
very shitty on
chicago
i'm assuming that's where the the kid
was conceived or something well no
kanye's from grew up in chicago is what
i'm assuming shout out chicago i know i
love you guys so much i need my kid
chicago
ian thoughts
thoughts what are you afraid of ian
i mean i think they
they call her like shy is that better or
worse
shy's like kind of cute too like chai
town chai no yeah like oh chai or shy i
think shy
i think i've heard them call caller that
i mean i know
how you're getting that from chicago but
i mean that's that's a fine nickname i
suppose
um
there you have it
i think it's weird i don't like it
it's pete davidson seems very
uh unstable
i think he he does this love bombing
thing you hear about when people have
like
he's like bipolar
i think he loved bombs
and then his relationships fall apart
like
i don't know he's just trying so hard
uh and he did the same thing with ariana
grande they were engaged and then i
think she left him because he was just
getting too [ __ ] it was being too
much
ian do you know anything about that
because i know you're a big fan of
ariana as well
what why they broke up yeah
i mean i it wasn't long after mac miller
passed away i don't know how much that
played into things because that she was
with him for a few years and then
started dating him right after so i
don't know i don't see how that would
affect it i mean they i mean clearly she
could mourn the passing of her
ex-boyfriend
but at the same time why would that
affect her current relationship maybe
she wasn't over it
you know people are complicated but then
she got like engaged the next month to a
different guy
you know
sometimes people
do things in relationships that aren't
necessarily wise all right anyway let's
talk about elon musk i've been putting
this off for a while
and we've got a lot of really good stuff
here elon has completely lost his
[ __ ] marbles
as you guys know he's planning on buying
tesla
for
what oh twitter
for like 50 billion dollars or something
nuts
the figure wound up being 44 i believe
44 billion so 44 billion a lot of people
are saying it's not going to happen
which is really interesting we'll see
now
separately i'm just i'm getting really
fed up with twitter it's just
increasingly becoming
i think it's so funny that him and all
these conservatives think that twitter
is like this super important town square
and i really feel in my bones that
twitter is just the least important
thing uh in my life and it's just
i go there and to feel bad basically you
know everybody's fighting
politics is going like nuts there it's
all about like owning the dunking
dunking
and it's just
it's just such a time sink in the worst
way possible
that i just find it really funny that
these people think it's so important
because it's not it's just not
well this was funny the day i started
taking wellbutrin elon musk or like the
day after he says well buchen is way
worse than adderall it should be taken
off the market every time that drug
comes up in conversation someone at the
table has a unaliving or near unaliving
story
which is super weird because well buchen
is like a very well researched and uh
widely
considered a safe and effective drug
uh you know so
it's like dude you really gotta stop
with these
hot takes that's just really [ __ ] up
now before i started antidepressants i
had a friend
who was like begging me
begging me he's like please don't take
it please don't take it i took it and i
tried to un-alive myself and it was a
horrible the worst thing please he's
like don't take it and he went up to
healings i promise he promised me that
you won't let him take it
which actually made me feel really bad
and really kind of scared to take it and
it put off
taking it
for a long time which actually he did me
a big disservice by taking it
and the action of taking it was
made really scary and uncomfortable for
for no reason
i almost didn't take it so
it's like you're not a [ __ ] doctor
i don't know what you're doing with the
medicine you know i later found out the
guy who was like don't take it don't
take it i had a horrible experience i
mean the guy's doing drugs every weekend
like heavy drugs and then you cannot mix
uh antidepressants especially ssris
which luxe pro is with the with drugs
like md acid even alcohol you don't want
to mix it with too too heavily
weed so he's so like
he doesn't he it's he's no right to say
that to me and it really [ __ ] me up
for a long time and i and i actually
resented the way he talked about it
because it put me off it for so long
in truth when you working closely with a
psychiatrist it's completely safe
especially under psychiatric
supervision supervision so
you know these drugs help a lot of
people
in a big way
and the way that he just writes this off
like this
is really [ __ ] disgusting
you know and like elon musk is someone
who's basically known to be like a micro
doser and it's like yeah if you're ta if
you're doing acid on a regular basis i
don't think you should take wellbutrin
or any any of these psychiatric drugs
it's not meant to work with those kinds
of things
so i don't know what your situation is
but it's really [ __ ] up to put that
out there because i know wellbutrin is
actually
a really uh
valid
uh very
you know very safe drug a very effective
drug
um
see a lot of people in the chat saying
that uh wellbutrin did a lot of good for
them
i saw lots of people responding to him
like dude you can't i well beach and
saved my life
somebody just donated ten dollars
abigail the well-being there
well thank you abigail you said well
buchen saved my life i have clinical
depression and wellbutrin was the game
changer that helped me make significant
changes in my life now i'm happily
married and working my dream job
that's what i'm saying you know
i i was i was poisoned by this stigma
like what he's saying here for so long
that i never actually
sought the help that i need i see a lot
of people saying well beach and saved my
life someone here said well butcher made
me uh want to un-alive myself
well i mean people have different
reactions to it and that's why you
should do it under supervision yeah
psychiatric supervision is really
important and they'll get you off of it
obviously the thing that the thing
that's interesting about wellbutrin2 is
that my doctor said you can just stop
taking it if you're
if you're not feeling off yeah my my
thing a lot of people are saying well
beach and save my life my thing with
like if you're going to if you're
getting feelings of uh self-harm and
stuff
um
i think there's usually
there's other stuff going on but i again
i'm not a doctor i don't know
but if you're having issues obviously
work with a psychiatrist don't take
[ __ ] advice from elon musk on twitter
you know
so there's a lot of people saying
negative things about buchen
but
there you have it
someone said welbuchen's the only
anti-depressant that doesn't worsen my
atd
that's the thing there's there with the
with the met with the psychiatric
medicine
it's basically a game of whackable
there's ones that work widely like
lexapro is like kind of the gold
standard
so a lot of psychiatrists will start
with that and if it's not working if
it's having negative side effects they
take you off that and they try you
another one and some mix well with
others that's why it's important to work
with a psychiatrist for whatever reasons
our brains just don't aren't receptive
to the same drugs as everyone else a lot
of people saying
zoloft this and that and what this sent
me to the hospital and that
that's why you've got to work with a
psychiatrist that's it you know
but saying it should be taken off the
market
it's just [ __ ] stupid bro like [ __ ]
you
imagine you're one of those people that
well beach and save their life you know
anyway that that that tweet was really
ignorant it actually just made me upset
because that's not just like political
posturing and weird free speech
obsession it's actually just
like bad medical advice like keemstar
level [ __ ] you know three sips of beer
kind of [ __ ]
i believe he uh ian correct me if i'm
wrong he deleted this one
did he i think so i couldn't find it
well that's that's interesting
so he may have actually he got roasted
pretty hard for this sweet yeah of all
the ones i think people were like man
[ __ ] this guy
and then he goes on what really bothers
me about keemstar i just call him
keemstar about elon musk's recent
twitter behavior is the people he's
hobnobbing with like mike cernovich who
is a like
[ __ ]
lunatic
conspiracy theorist
scamming [ __ ] one of the weirdest
dudes on the internet
he sells the thing a formulation he made
himself called gorilla brain
actually maybe you can pull it up
because um
[Music]
vic berger made a really [ __ ] great
edit about uh
mike cernovich's gorilla brain so i'd
like to watch that
mike cernovich uh also famously um
was one of the main people that got the
pizzagate thing going right so that was
his that's his claim to fame he's just a
psychotic uh
conspiracy theorist in the worst way
oh
he was the one that got sam cedar fired
from msnbc too over total [ __ ] oh
really yeah which he eventually he's
i don't know if he still is but i think
eventually they moved past that or
whatever but
yeah
cancel call to run amok
um
so i just find it interesting that i'm
sure he gets lots of this guy posted
some [ __ ] about wellbutrin
uh paying doctors to
uh
recommend wellbutrin
and then elon musk responds no kidding
the thing is whenever elon musk responds
he boosts the person he's responding to
so much
and it just turns out all the people
he's responding to
are like
deep deep conservative scumbags
you all know what vic
i mean
mike cernovich if you know anything
about him is not a legit dude
this was really embarrassing
you made a few edits so i'm not sure if
this was the one you're remembering this
isn't the gorilla brain one though
vic burger had this whole feud with him
but just type gorilla brain
mike cernovich vic berger it should show
up
this game was really [ __ ]
embarrassing man in 2007 here we go here
we go the blue building
is going to be um focusing on unity how
can we bring people together because
people are a lot of people losing their
minds
yeah you know crazy just relax
it's okay
okay just relax relax this is okay
i got blue pills literally
blue pills
stimulant resting
it's a supplement that i'm formulating
it's my unique nootropic
gorilla mind so it's my own formula
it's okay
[Music]
and we're back mike cernovich danger of
oh hey shawna
shawna june
would you bring me up three blue pills
please
[Music]
you brought them up here i know but then
i brought them downstairs for some dumb
reason girl of mine
[Music]
what are the ingredients i'll tell you
later i'm not i'm not trying to market
myself it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter what's in it hillary
clinton literally trying to have me
killed so
[Music]
oh yeah success isn't easy don't get me
wrong don't get me wrong success is not
easy and it's lonely at the top
only at the time the bigger you get the
more people want to take you out hillary
clinton was literally trying to have me
killed
so
yeah
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
okay
yeah if you're thinking that's like a
weird adult swim edit you're right
because vic berger great editor by the
way works with tim heidecker
a lot every year
so this is this is just a brief glimpse
into the world of
candidates
autoplayed the next video uh the brief
were a glimpse into the world of mike
cernovich so that's just one
this meme other
this is
this is [ __ ] the dumbest [ __ ] you
guys
here's him 2008
he's a left of center he's a lib
fellow liberals conservatives 2012 oh
the liberals are spreading to the left
but the conservatives haven't moved oh
it's 2021. now he's a conservative
the conservatives still haven't moved
but look at the liberals they went all
the way over here
it's incredible he tweeted this out
uh despite the fact that
you know the conservatives haven't moved
at all right
they haven't stormed the capital in a
bid to overthrow
fair and free election also
2008 barack obama was elected to the
president of the united states
the current president united states is
his vice president
who is arguably to the right of barack
obama
no not according to this meme
i mean you know it's like you you
literally have in florida the most
prominent uh con
basically the two most prominent
republican governors one is desantis in
florida who's doing the don't say gay
bill
and then you have another one in texas
where they're basically outlawing
abortion making a criminal
acting like trans people are
[ __ ] freaks that shouldn't you
shouldn't be even allowed to talk about
them these people are
they're sprinting to the right they're
becoming more and more unhinged they
don't even have
real issues they care about their only
issue is talking about how [ __ ] up
democrats are or con or progressives are
i mean this meme is like straight up
propaganda that he's tweeting out
um it's [ __ ] nuts
uh
so this is this is pretty pathetic i
thought
and then dude he's been on a tear and
then he posted tim poole meme by the way
tim was begging him to come on the show
and he ignored him which is great
uh
here he is
responding i'm trying to find him
responding to here's steven crowder as
you guys all know he's coming and
and it's not even like insightful
comment right it's mostly just to be
like i see you and i like you and i want
it's just that's the same thing he did
with cernovich
he's a reply guy he says no kidding
he's trying to boost it he knows what
happens when he's stephen
crowder you guys know stephen crowder
the government is creating a
misinformation governance board who else
did something like that oh i remember
the nazis there's some data showing that
some interesting things are going on
uh elon musk's twitter takeover
discomforting
what was the deal with that whole
missing from the misinformation
department oh that is really [ __ ]
stupid i'm not gonna lie
so that's a real thing
uh yeah apparently and like the the czar
this disinformation czar they hired is
people immediately dug up a lot of
really cringe things about her but
yeah
well you got into it on this thursday
he's signal boosting stephen crowder
again yeah that's the uh and i'll be
honest with you as much as i hate
stephen crowder and think he's a giant
piece of [ __ ] mike cernovich is actually
even worse
he's like yeah he's like a dangerous
conspiracy theory lunatic yeah he's
pretty bad
you don't even have to think about it
dude and then of course boosting ben
shapiro
uh elon musk twitter should be
politically neutral the washington post
in every left-wing blue check mark
you guys are giving away your game this
is this is so funny to me that they're
pretending like every progressive is
losing their mind i mean i don't think
most people give a [ __ ] like i think
it's one thing to acknowledge that like
this is kind of [ __ ] weird that
elon's taking over twitter i don't think
anyone's having a meltdown
and we said on the other day i mean we
can only speak for us but
i mean
we don't care it's
far
what it's going from being owned by a
[ __ ] blackrock and a bunch of like
anonymous saudi investors right
to another rich dude yeah rich people
own social media companies this isn't
actually
ground shaking in any way
kevin by the way said well beach is the
best thing to ever happen to me so there
you go thank you kevin
uh elon musk responds to ben shapiro he
says attacks are coming thick and fast
primary from the left which is no
surprise however i should be clear that
the right will probably be unhappy too
my goal is to maximize
area under the curve of total human
happiness which means 80 percent of the
people in the middle
what do you think about that
i mean
i i think he's actually right in that
if this deal goes through which like you
alluded to earlier i'm actually getting
more and more skeptical that this thing
is actually going to happen but let's
just presuppose
he ends up buying twitter and he owns it
um
i don't see how this doesn't because
everybody on the right has just kind of
decided in their minds that this is a
big w for them and it's going to be the
return of you know free speech and they
won't be oppressed on twitter anymore
um the content moderation is not going
to change that significantly and people
are still gonna get banned and every
time they do
people are gonna now be pissed off at
elon musk like he's made himself
it's like we said the other day he's the
mod now everybody gets mad at the mods
like you've put yourself in a position
where no matter what you do everybody's
gonna be pissed off at you all the time
it just doesn't seem like a smart move
to be the king of twitter
and then dave rubin which is probably
the dumbest conservative alive if you
can even call him that i think he's just
guys dave rubin's the dumbest dude man
bro that guy is so dumb
hey elon as long as you're digging check
out how new york times and forbes
uh bought their twitter followers to
fake influence new york has new york
times has 50 million followers and
rarely gets 50 retweets
i could post a banana emoji and a
picture of 86 home star game i mean a
lot of that's a lot of big accounts
elon again yeah i noticed that pretty
weird okay thanks for the insight bro
thanks for boosting dave rubin
back with cernovich he responded to him
twice
oh big fan
dude
uh whatever whatever he says sounds
pretty bad again it's like you why are
you even you didn't need to sit you're
just boosting his post
mike cernovich man you should probably
just not do that yeah can you find
another cernovich edit by vic because
they're all good
i just want to show you guys what a
[ __ ] nut case this guy is
in his uh
here's a i don't know who this guy tom
elliott is but he says nbc
if the neo-nazi faction of the gop
expands we may look back on this as a
pitiful moment when a petulant and not
so bright billionaire casually brought
one of the most
influential messaging machines and just
handed it to the far right i think
that's a bit alarmist but
he responded
nbc basically saying all republicans are
nazis
i don't think that's what they said but
yeah i i think that all they definitely
didn't ian you watched the clip what was
it that he said exactly that i mean i
could link the clip if you want to see
sure because it's it's actually
interesting look not all naughts not all
republicans are nazis but all nazis are
probably republicans
or at least trend that way i think it's
fair to say yeah they're conservative
yes
and then elon continued same org that
covered up hunter biden laptop story
had her
harvey weinstein story early and killed
it and built matt lauer his our office
well i'm not defending them but nbc
sucks yeah i'm not let's not get twisted
here i'm not defending him
but but you just see the slan he's got
an agenda that's kind of nuts
and again i mean let's let's take a look
at the clip that that is in reaction to
and you tell me if that's an appropriate
response okay
in american discourse to talk
simplistically about the far left and
the far right as two equally dangerous
fringe blocks
elon musk has done it plenty of times
just in the past week
but here's the difference america's far
left wants to give us free health care
and free child care america's far right
wants to give us white supremacy and no
democracy he he's right asymmetrical
polarization of u.s politics would be
laughable if it weren't so horrifying
we are living through an unspeakably
dangerous moment the pro-q anon
pro-neo-nazi faction of the republican
party is poised to expand dramatically
come the midterms so that's the key
right there the pro hold on hold on
somebody in chat said nazis are
historically socialist national
associates read a book read a book bro
they're not social they're national
socialists oh my god
please dude seriously it's such a such a
such an entire talking point i just
wanted to address that real fast yeah
please
uh yeah so basically what he's saying is
the
he specifically says a faction of the
republican party that is queuing on and
republican party is poised to excuse a
non-pro dangerous moment the pro-q anon
pro-neo-nazi faction of the republican
party is poised to expand dramatically
come the midterms right so he's specific
he's not saying he's saying the opposite
not all republicans he's talking about
a subset of republicans that are
queuing on he says nbc basically saying
republicans are nazis no i mean that's
just propaganda it's just not what he
said he just wants to be part of this
victim culture
he goes the far left hates everyone
themselves included
i don't even know what the [ __ ] that's
supposed to mean
but i'm no fan of the right either guys
let's do less hate and more love anyway
mike cernovich what do you have to say
who literally uh
bullying is not leadership what are you
talking about i'm just saying twitter
needs to be politically neutral
how did he even know that was about him
i think that was some some staff member
of twitter or something oh oh oh oh wow
he's coming after
interesting
for twitter to deserve public trust it
must be politically neutral which
effectively means upsetting the far
right and the far left equally
again this whole idea that that twitter
is like a far left platform is weird to
me
i i don't see any evidence of that
alexander aoc said tired of having to
collectively stress about what explosion
of hate crimes is happening because some
billionaire with an ego problem
unilaterally controls a massive
communication platform and skews it
because tucker carlson or peter thiel
took him to dinner and made him feel
special
and of course elon musk with the
of an eight-year-old said stop hitting
on me i'm really shy
which they loved
then that was all it was trending on
twitter like elon loves or aoc loves
elon
so she actually responded with something
that was [ __ ] hilarious but then she
deleted it and i don't yeah i don't know
why she said i was talking about
zuckerberg but okay
which is probably because she's like
good response but probably because she
was she felt it was too jokey and like
you don't want to
it's kind of was a light response and
she probably doesn't want to
have like any rapport with him you know
i guess
i always thought that was a great
response
yeah so he just keeps stealing other
people's jokes too was real interesting
now i'm going to buy mcdonald's and fix
all the ice cream machines i was
watching a late night show or no was
bill maher
and he's like elon tweeted out this
hilarious joke about how next i'm going
to buy coke and put the cocaine back in
it and it's funny because last week
where we saw that he our i saw he he
that was a carbon copy of a comedian's
jokes that he literally ripped and
people are being like oh look how funny
elon is like bro what the [ __ ] what does
that say about your businesses when
you're just willing leaders to rip
people off and post without credit like
brazenly
unapologetically i mean that says
something about him i think
um
i don't know i i hate these association
with all these conservative guys it
makes me uncomfortable
i mean has you been responding to any
like people like hassan you know what i
mean
it's only the [ __ ] i don't think he'd
go anywhere how is he gonna talk about
political neutrality and then he's just
he's a reply girl to uh
every like fringe conservative media
person
how is that politically neutral yeah
because
he's not it's just [ __ ]
by the way bill maher sucks now i used
to like him but he won't shut the [ __ ]
up about covet and it's really annoying
the more sucks ass i'm glad you said it
i used to like him but like i don't know
i find the show impossible to watch now
but the guy the the host was right i
mean the the fringe right is
basically anti-democratic
white supremacist
yeah i mean are we denying conspiracy
theorists a component of
republican voters that are super into
queuing on and [ __ ] well a lot of course
like a fat chunk of them yeah they're
big time even if you go and ask
politicians now
and say who won the election almost none
of them are going to give you a straight
up response to that question
none of them
that should tell you something so what
is the fringe left what's like the most
radical left
well the thing is is that the the
what i would probably point to as the
fringe or radical left is generally not
even participants in electoral politics
or in the democratic party whatsoever i
mean the extreme like anarchists
or or people that are like members of
the dsa i mean that isn't even that
extreme but you know they they're third
party you know what i mean they're not
in the general like if you want to point
to the extreme left of at least the
national democratic party you're
pointing at like ill on omar and aoc
which aren't they're not that extreme
which is what it's accurate what he said
these people just want basic human
rights they want health care they want
child care they want free college they
don't want young people to be in debt
that all sounds [ __ ] great
yeah and i mean the fact of the matter
is you know where the policy direction
of this country is going right now even
with the democrats in control of
both chambers of congress and the
presidency
you know were backsliding on
you know abortion is probably going to
become illegal in the next year or so
um if the supreme court has its way and
you know biden wasn't able to pass any
of his
you know build back better or not any of
it but a huge amount of it
um universal healthcare isn't coming
student debt cancellation is going to be
like 10k off or something uh
which is good but not enough yeah i mean
the the ex extreme left is not winning
or or or in control of anything right i
mean
basically talking about the perception
of this joke is like
uh
being a conservative is when i can say
the n word
right yeah like genuinely i don't know
where what this perception is
uh you know being conservative means
being able to be racist and not people
not getting mad at you
i don't know i don't know what they're
talking about
what is this where what the [ __ ]
it's such propaganda
yeah i mean again if like joe biden is
president
you know the democratic party has not
moved very far left if joe biden is the
president right now if bernie had won
you could maybe make an argument that
it's moved significantly to the left but
he didn't
it's joe [ __ ] biden
well what's weird too is all these
people love bernie like joe rogan and
elon musk they all apparently oh they
love
not like bernie no no okay
billionaires shouldn't like bernie no
yeah he's he's like beefed with him on
twitter before he's like always trying
to
you know [ __ ] with him no that is
definitely not a thing but yeah i mean
rogan said he was gonna vote for him at
one point so yeah no he yeah exactly i
mean he had him on the show and i got
him on the show and heard him out and he
was like yeah i like this guy
so
that's that i just find it really weird
that this i mean the conservatives
they're just so effective with this
propaganda like they can convince people
of [ __ ] anything dude
um
it's really amazing what is the left
that like being pro trans
is that how the people on the left went
too far
being like in favor of of people of
trans people having a right to exist
without feeling like
like
uh freaks i mean i think that's a big
culture war thing
gay people getting rights trans people
getting rights abort being having legal
abortion is that what's radical left
you know
yeah
there you have it folks there you have
it
um
i
have to go soon okay good i have an
appointment to get to oh here's when he
interacted with bernie by the way
we must demand that the extremely
wealthy pair pay their fair share period
which is like
you know obviously so offensive he says
i keep forgetting you're still alive
[ __ ] no you didn't you worry you dream
of him in your sleep you have nightmares
about bernie coming for
to tax your ass
you wake up in a cold sweat with bernie
and the irs at your door you didn't
forget he's alive you're [ __ ]
constantly in fear
i'm sorry but like bro have some class
that's just
like that's pathetic dude
by the way you know i drive a tesla
there's a bunch of eevee cars coming out
and i'm really excited to say that me
and ela are going to be turning in our
tesla when the lease is up and getting
uh one of these new electric cars
like bmw's coming out with an
all-electric suv
that we're gonna pre-order it looks
[ __ ] awesome you're gonna get the
beamer
yeah that that seems like the best one
available for suv
sure it's called like that
it looks great
i love bmw you are okay that's fun then
oh yeah it's just
the ix yeah that's with like the color
changing um
there's there's one car that's coming
out they have a color changing paint
like the the paint changes color yeah i
didn't see that uh but i saw it yeah
based on what like
in the temperature outside or something
no you can control it
yeah it's really cool wait that goes
i don't think that's coming out on this
car it might be a concept but i saw it
inside there yeah i saw that video too
it's crazy huh yeah
but like dude have some [ __ ] class
man like damn
i'm sorry but bernie sanders entirely he
served our country for for his whole
life
he's a valiant and resp and and a
respected uh you know public servant
like
[ __ ] me dude what the [ __ ]
i mean
right
i believe he's still one of the most
popular uh
politicians in
national government
even now
i don't know pretty [ __ ] tasteless
tweet
but yeah you know damn well he's still
alive so don't [ __ ] in front
but um i'm just really excited to be
able to because the i love the electric
thing i think it's really important and
so i'm really glad to be able to support
other
companies
it doesn't come out until like we order
it now and then we get it like the
beginning of next year okay
that's that's awesome i mean it's super
cool that and i think by the way
once more competition starts coming out
a lot of companies are working with for
electric vehicles i agree tesla cars are
super [ __ ] overrated they suck
but they are the only really good
polished option
or something for a while but yeah so
changing soon dude tesla is gonna
it's gonna
uh tank big time once all the
competition comes out i've been looking
for an electric and and there's a lot
coming there's a lot out right now that
are kind of interesting yeah hyundai has
a couple that i really like and
coming really soon dude [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's finally here because i i just
gotta say like these traditional car
companies have been making cars for like
100 years
they are gonna make such a better
product than tesla i think
yeah i mean uh
i've heard a lot of horror stories about
the
quality control on tesla's i don't know
if you've expected i never had a problem
with my cars i've had two teslas and
they're both uh
you know i've been reliable they're
brand new cars though but like just the
inside the construction is kind of
shoddy like everything just feels kind
of janky inside that's what i hear yeah
like yeah it's just the the qc is not
the best definitely yeah how do you
gonna get to try european quality now
with the bmw oh i'm so excited
i'm so excited
your w's are so good yeah okay howdy
e-tron's really that's a cool car too
tv as well
bro i'm so i'm so [ __ ] tired of my
rolls-royce so annoying that i have that
car i regret it not because of the i
regret it because one
it's such a flashy car i don't like the
attention yeah you know i don't like
everyone [ __ ] looking at me and
shouting at me and being like nice car
bro
hey what do you do for a living
just roll up the window
and then second of all obviously it has
horrible gas mileage
the interior are so old too like holy
[ __ ]
it's kind of an old person's car a
little bit so i'm and you know i had to
do a four year lease for this [ __ ]
thing oh no you're [ __ ] four [ __ ]
years they got my ass you can't trade in
early or something oh i guess well no
i could but i'd have to get another like
rolls royce yeah
rip so by the time this thing expires
when you live by the meme you die by the
meme you bought it you bought a car on
me i think you could get out of it early
i you have to pay
i'd have to pay like [ __ ] [ __ ]
money i feel like you can make it i
shouldn't say that word i apologize i
think depending on the dude stupid money
you could make a deal to get out of it
it's a desirable car i'm just saying you
think i could have someone like take
over the lease
oh maybe yeah oh that would be actually
a good idea
i don't know how you would go about it
give you one quarter no that's probably
still way too much i'll give you you
want to know how much it costs a month
this is going to make people angry if i
say how much it cost a month i mean
i guess saying it probably will but
anybody people should know that that is
an extremely expensive car i'm very
sorry for saying the r word guys please
forgive me
i meant
oh my god
yeah i apologize i will go to the podium
everyone so
they just heard the uh the r word drop
and now everyone's going crazy
um
yeah i don't know i i regret getting the
the rolls royce
should i say how much it cost a month i
mean if it's just going to piss people
off i guess not
i mean we can all assume i don't know
how much it is a month but i would guess
it's a lot yes
i'd say 500 a month
oh yeah that's pretty good guess yeah i
would have said like four grand a month
or something
they're good guesses they're good
guesses yeah
yikes yeah no that's absurd i know it
sucks it's painful
i did it for the meme you know and it
was fun and funny and good content yeah
yeah but now i'm stuck with this [ __ ]
car for
four or four goddamn years
someone said 10k it's not that much a
month it's not that much but you know
the insurance is insane you're right of
course
you know the insurance alone was like a
thousand dollars a month
oh i'm telling you you could get out of
it
i would love to get a new a different
car dude i would love to
you know
what would you get the show doesn't need
people are basically guessing it right
so i think it's like 5500 a month
so he nailed it plus a thousand in
insurance well it's a 6 500 a month and
it gets 14 miles per gallon because it
has a v12
jesus v12 yeah v12 what's the horsepower
on that it's insane it's like a six
seven hundred so it hauls it's not like
yeah no it's fast as [ __ ] sure yeah but
god damn yeah but the thing is like you
guys saw when i went to the dealership
and got it i didn't think about it i was
like i'm just doing it
i didn't check the mileage i didn't look
at the price i didn't
i didn't [ __ ]
uh i barely even looked at the interior
you were in a position where you could
just be like all right [ __ ] it i'm just
gonna do it which you know i admire you
know you haven't made a content it was
on no it was it was a funny it was funny
trisha's gone and the [ __ ] rolls
royce remains exactly
i'm telling you you could get out of it
though yeah the mileage is insane
i have to leave you have to leave you
don't have to end the show so if any if
anybody in the chat wants to take over
my lease it's 55 500 tomorrow a month
reach out
but how do i go about getting someone to
take over the lease though well i mean
look
you find the right dealer you find the
right car i'm sure they can work out a
deal
so i just called the dealer and [ __ ]
well not necessarily where you got it
but
you you go and
you shop around and be like hey i gotta
get out of this
although because it is how long have you
had it a year two years uh about a year
probably you could go to the dealer and
be like look there's gonna be some
negative equity but if you could roll
over
the rolls into a new car they got to
make a deal no but they only have rolls
royces there
right i'm saying you don't have to go to
that dealer oh you think a duff
different dealer would buy my lease yeah
let's say you go to bmw or porsche or
whatever whatever
yeah depending on the deal but i'd have
to pay them a bunch of money i feel like
but you could roll the negative equity
into the
new car
i'm rolling negative equity into the new
car
i don't even know what that means
i'm telling you call a dealer be like
look i want to get this yeah i'm looking
to roll some negative equity
yeah okay
if you want to get out of it early you
can maybe i can have leno to help me
because she's she's good are you back
dan what happened
your giant rolls royce is actually
blocking me okay let's wrap it up i'll
let you out yeah
all right guys thanks for watching was a
fun episode we covered a lot of ground
on wednesday oliver is gonna call in and
then oh we also have what we all have
stuff going on this week what else
oh bobby's on friday
[Music]
anyway guys thank you so much
appreciate y'all
i gotta go unblock dan
uh thanks for watching everybody see on
wednesday peace and love peace and love
[Music]
[Music]
you